welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday
[Music]
life I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a
professor of neurobiology and
Opthalmology at Stanford School of
Medicine my guest today is Dr Karen
Parker Dr Karen Parker directs the
social neurosciences research program at
the Stanford University School of
Medicine the goal of her laboratory's
research is to understand the biological
basis of social functioning at every St
age of the lifespan so this includes the
bonds that form between infant and
parent or parents as well as the bonds
that occur between children as they grow
up which of course form the template for
social functioning when we become adults
Dr Parker's research is heavily focused
on autism and indeed on all forms of
autism spectrum disorders today we
discuss autism we talk about the
prominent theories and current
understanding of the biological basis
for autism as well as what Still Remains
mysterious and unresolved D about the
causes of autism you may have heard that
the incidence or perhaps just the
diagnosis of autism has dramatically
increased in the last 10 to 15 years and
today we discuss why it is in fact that
the incidence not just the diagnosis but
the incidence of autism has so
dramatically increased and perhaps most
excitingly Dr Parker shares with us
brand new research findings from her
laboratory that point to a new
understanding of what causes autism as
well as a novel treatment for autism
before we begin I'd like to emphasize
that this podcast is separate from my
teaching and research roles at Stanford
it is however part of my desire and
effort to bring zero cost to Consumer
information about science and science
related tools to the general public in
keeping with that theme I'd like to
thank the sponsors of today's podcast
our first sponsor is eight sleep eight
sleep makes Smart mattress covers with
cooling Heating and sleep tracking
capacity I've spoken many times before
in this podcast about the fact that
sleep is the foundation of mental health
physical health and performance now a
key component of getting a great night's
sleep is that in order to fall and stay
deeply asleep your body temperature
actually has to drop by about one to 3°
and in order to wake up feeling
refreshed and energized your body
temperature actually has to increase by
about 1 to 3° one of the best ways to
make sure that those temperature changes
occur at the appropriate times at the
beginning and throughout and at the end
of your night when you wake up is to
control the temperature of your sleeping
environment and that's what eight sleep
allows you to do it allows you to
program the temperature of your mattress
and sleeping environment such that you
fall and stay deeply asleep easily and
wake up each morning feeling incredibly
refreshed and energized I've been
sleeping on an eights Sleep mattress
cover for almost 3 years now and it has
dramatically improved the quality of my
sleep so much so that when I travel and
I'm at a hotel or an Airbnb and I don't
have access to my eight sleep I very
much look forward to getting home
because my sleep is always better when I
sleep on my eight Sleep mattress cover
if you'd like to try eights sleep you
can go to 8sleep.com
huberman to get $50 off their pod 3
mattress cover eight sleep currently
ships in the USA Canada UK select
countries in the EU and Australia again
that's 8sleep.com
huberman today's episode is also brought
To Us by element element is an
electrolyte drink that has everything
you need and nothing you don't that
means zero sugar and the appropriate
ratios of the electrolyte sodium
magnesium and potassium and that correct
ratio of electrolytes is extremely
important because every cell in your
body but especially your nerve cells
your ner neurons relies on electrolytes
in order to function properly so when
you're well hydrated and you have the
appropriate amount of electrolytes in
your system your mental functioning and
your physical functioning is improved I
drink one packet of element dissolved in
about 16 to 32 ounces of water when I
wake up in the morning as well as while
I exercise and if I've sweat a lot
during that exercise I often will drink
a third element packet dissolved in
about 32 ounces of water after I
exercise element comes in a variety of
different flavors all of which I find
really tasty I like the Citrus I like
the watermelon I like the raspberry
frankly I can't pick just one it also
comes in chocolate and chocolate mint
which I find tastes best if they are put
into water dissolved and then heated up
I tend to do that in the winter months
because of course you don't just need
hydration on hot days and in the summer
and spring months but also in the winter
when the temperatures are cold and the
environment tends to be dry if you'd
like to try element you can go to drink
element spelled lm.com huberman to try a
free sample pack again that drink
element.com
huberman today's episode is also brought
To Us by Aeropress Aeropress is similar
to a French press for making coffee but
is in fact a much better way to make
coffee I first learned about Aeropress
well over 10 years ago and I've been
using one ever since Aeropress was
developed by Allan Adler who was an
engineer at Stanford and I knew of Allan
because he had also built the so-called
aobi frisbee which I believe at one time
perhaps still now held the Guinness Book
of World Records for furthest thrown
object and I used to see Allan believe
it or not at parks around paloalto
testing out different aobi frisbe so he
was sort of famous in our community for
developing these different Feats of
engineering that turned into commercial
products now I love coffee I'm somebody
that drinks coffee nearly every day
usually about 90 to 120 minutes after I
wake up in the morning although not
always sometimes if I'm going into
exercise I'll drink coffee first thing
in the morning but I love love love
coffee and what I've personally found is
that by using the Arrow Press I can make
the best possible tasting cup of coffee
I don't know what exactly it is in the
Aero press that allows the same beans to
be prepared into a cup of coffee that
tastes that much better as compared to
any other form of Brewing that coffee
even the traditional French press the
Aero press is extremely easy to use and
it's extremely compact in fact I take it
with me whenever I travel and I use it
on the road in hotels even on planes
I'll just ask for some hot water and
I'll Brew my coffee coffee or tea right
there on the plane if you'd like to try
Aeropress you can go to Aero press.com
huberman that's a r o
p.com huberman to get 20% off any
Aeropress coffee maker Aeropress ships
anywhere in the USA Canada and over 60
other countries around the world again
that's Aeropress
docomond to get 20% off and now for my
discussion with Dr Karen Parker Dr Karen
Parker welcome thank you it's great to
be here this is going to be perhaps one
of the longer conversations that we've
been able to have over the years um in
part because whenever I see you on
campus we're headed in our respective
directions but I'm very excited because
the topic of autism is one that is on a
lot of people's minds and I think the
first question that always comes up it
seems is whether or not the frequency of
autism is indeed increasing or whether
or not the field of medicine is is
getting better at detecting what was
always there over time do we have any
clear answers to that well I think it's
a multifactorial answer so we're getting
better at detecting autism right so in
the past we were diagnosing kids at nine
or 10 years of age right and now
clinicians are able to reliably diagnose
kids um at two to three years of age
right so there's more people um there
are pediatricians have autism screeners
now so when you bring in your baby and
over the first couple years of life
you're filling out screeners that are
looking for autism symptoms right so so
there's just a lot more awareness around
autism but the rates have increased to
now 136 us children have a diagnosis of
autism which is over two years ago it
was 1 in 44 so 1 in
36 wow I feel like it was just yesterday
when it was 1 in 80 but is 1 in 36 um
the average across Bo and girls um does
it
skew differently if you look at just
male births versus female births yeah
that's a great question so autism is
male biased and prevalence so you have
and again the studies veryy I mean it's
it's worth noting that autism is a
highly clinically heterogeneous disorder
which means that if you met one kid with
autism you've met one kid with autism
right so so we have to bear that in mind
as we have this conversation but you
know different studies show that about
for every one girl there's three to four
boys that are impacted by autism so
there's you know differences in the
prevalence rate and also there's
different monitoring sites so the way in
the US that these data are generated is
the CDC has 11 monitoring sites across
the country and so they they follow um
children and then that's where we um
that's where the prevalence rates come
from and they release new prevalence
rates every you know few years so if
Physicians are able ble to detect autism
early say in a 2-year-old or a
three-year-old have to imagine that
they're working off of tests that don't
rely heavily on language because even
though you can get you know some verbose
two and three year olds most two and
three-year-olds don't have a very
extensive vocabulary um and I'm guessing
that they're also relying on things like
visual gaze um among other things um
we've already made clear that this is um
not a discussion to allow people to
diagnose themselves or others but um
with that said what are some of the
diagnostic tools that people use you
know um is it language is it Vision or
does it present as um you know abnormal
auditory processing maybe you could give
us a sampling so autism is um a
behavioral diagnosis right so unlike
other areas of medicine where you might
be able to take a blood test or there's
other sort of tools it's all a
behavioral diagnosis by um an expert so
usually um a psychiatrist or a
psychologist and they look for two core
features so the so this is based on the
DSM um five and there the two core
features are pervasive social
interaction challenges and the presence
of restricted repetitive Behavior but
there are a lot of people with Autism
who have anxiety there are a lot of
people with sensory challenges there are
a lot of people with seizure disorder
um Sleep Disorders so again it's each
person with autism has this sort of
unique collection of traits and you know
that's how they get diagnosed we're
going to talk a lot today about
interventions but how early are some of
the behavioral interventions and I
should just say any interventions
introduced nowadays so if someone brings
their child to the pediatrician and they
take one of these tests and that a child
is deemed as having autism um um will
the will the one-year-old or the you
know two-year-old immediately go into
behavioral interventions well so usually
you need to have the diagnosis of autism
and then there are behavioral
interventions a variety of different
ones um that are used there are some
studies where um because autism is
highly heritable you can have one child
with autism and then you if you have
subsequent children you're at an
increased risk of having subsequent
children with autism and these are
called Baby sibling studies so what
you're doing is enriching the population
of infants that you follow
prospectively um who are more likely to
receive an Autism diagnosis and there
are studies where some of those children
are enrolled in Behavioral Studies even
when they're quote unquote at
risk I've heard before that you know
parents in which one or typically both
parents are say of the engineering mathy
physics quote unquote hard science
science type are um more likely to have
autistic children is that true I mean
did that bear out in the data you know
if you look at profession or or um you
know undergraduate major uh does any of
that correlate with the probability of
having an autistic child yeah well what
I can say is that there's been some
studies so what we know is that autistic
traits are continuously distributed
across the general population and there
was a study and there's a couple
different instruments that are used used
to be able to measure these autistic
traits so there's something called the
social responsiveness scale and then
that's a us-based instrument and there's
an Autism quotient that's a similar
measure that was um designed in England
and what what we know from work with the
AQ is that individuals that are in
intense stem Fields like engineering
physics and math have a greater burden
of autistic traits even if they don't
have an Autism
diagnosis okay so that leads me to
wonder whether or not this whole
business of a spectrum yeah is actually
multiple spectry spectrums is it
spectrums or spectry what someone will
put it in the in the comments on YouTube
we know that for sure please let me know
I would like to know what is the plural
of spectrum spectrums um you know
because when we hear the word spectrum
we think okay there's a spectrum of
severity right and in fact I have some
experience with um severe autism not in
my family but where I went to
undergraduate University uh UC Santa
Barbara down the way from that school
was the Deo school which was a school
which um has been there for a long time
that um parents would send their kids if
they were quote unquote severely
autistic it was actually where um Dustin
Hoffman went to um study for his role in
Rainman and the uh the kids who were
really delightful they used to come into
town every once in a while to the coffee
shop where I'd study and they would also
continue on from there to Kmart which is
why the Dustin Hoffman character would
say gotta go to Kmart gotta go to he
would do that repetition right that
Kmart was down the road from our you
know our College housing and the Deo
School those kids were literally in a um
away from home facility
full-time and I spoke to some of the
parents at one point and they were at
that facility meaning the parents had
sent them their children away to live
there full-time of course they'd get
visits and they'd get visits home um
because they were I suppose we could say
at the far end of some spectrum that
made it at least to the parents idea
impossible for them to be at home okay
now at the other end of the spectrum if
one is just simply thinking in terms of
severity I know people who have
self-identified as a autistic that's how
they've referred to it so I feel
comfortable um saying that they've said
I am autistic um and they seem pretty
high functioning meaning they have
driver's licenses drive cars are in
healthy relationships and manage life
apparently well um they have some traits
that yes I would agree are a little bit
different right so this is where we get
into neurode Divergence right um but I
guess the point is you know should we
think about autism as on a spectrum or
given the fact that there are these um
kind of collections of different traits
could there be a spectrum of severity
also a spectrum of um you know more
stereotype behaviors um another spectrum
that intersects with that that has to do
with you know obsession with a
particular topic you know you could
imagine that there are you know 50 or 60
different Spectra or spectrums I still
don't know which one to say and that
when we talk about the Spectrum we're
really talking about something that's in
multiple dimensions and not just one
line that goes from severe to mild does
that make sense yeah I mean I think this
is where understanding the biological
basis of behavior would then allow us to
be able to say you like here's these
different dimensions right but not
understanding the biology you're left
with okay we're are we lumpers or
Splitters like how do we think about
this because autism is highly heritable
so there's about 40 to 80% of autism is
um is genetic right so these vary wildly
right but the but the common thinking is
that the majority about 50% of autism is
um is associated with common genetic
variants and so the way that we've
always thought about this is that there
is this you know autism is largely an
inherited polygenic condition and but
what I mean by that is that you have a
lot of common variants that are additive
and so if you think about this
collection of common genetic variant
that underly the Spectrum right so if
you have less of a dosing of some of
these common variants you might see
somebody who's a lot more who's higher
functioning like you said and if you end
up with one of these single Gene High
penetrant um disorders you might see
severe intellectual disability and sort
of lower functioning on the other end of
the spectrum but I think that there is a
lot that we don't know and what you're
bringing up I think underlines you know
sort of an issue with autism autism
which is common for many brain disorders
which is like if you don't understand
the underlying biological basis it also
gets very difficult to diagnose and
treat right and that's where we are with
a lot of different you know psychiatric
and neurodevelopmental disorders to date
has there been any specific neural
network that we can point to and say Ah
that's the neural network that seems to
be different in people who are on the
autism spectrum um I saw a study
published recently that seemed to point
to the idea that the genes that are
altered in autism um at least include a
large number of genes that are altered
or the proteins that are the consequence
of those genes are altered
and exist at the synapse at the
connections between neurons and I'm
asking it that way because you know some
years ago I was at a talk on autism at
Stanford and someone raised their hand
and says um do we even know that autism
is a brain issue right could couldn't it
be an issue of you know the immune
system or the cardiovascular system
which at the time seemed like okay gosh
of course it's but wait then you stop
and you think that's a really good
question right how do we know it's a
it's a challenge of the brain right I
think that's a great question right and
there may be people talk about
just take for a moment that this is a
brain disorder how do you study it in
people right so you know it's very
difficult to get access to either
cerebral spinal fluid which is a fluid
that bathes the brain um brain tissue
biopsies it's very hard to get people
especially children that are really
impacted into a brain scanner right
because they can't sit still they may
have sensory issues they don't want to
go into a scanner right so a lot of the
tools that neuroscientists or or
psychiatrist have to think about looking
at the brain are um limited right and
then and then the other part is how do
you model so the other way we might
think about getting access or or
thinking about model systems what we
need to do is think about the control
animals and we need to make sure that
the species that we're modeling them in
has um features of control humans if you
will so we need to have complex
cognitive abilities we need to have
complex social skills we need to have an
organism that has Vision as its primary
sensory modality right potentially sleep
consolidating so we need to think about
all of those and and the the tricky part
I think until fairly recently was that
we were doing all of this work in Mouse
models and you know the control mice
just fundamentally lack many of the
characteristics that are needed to model
you know autism with Fidelity right and
I think that's you know when we look at
drug development pipelines about 50% of
preclinical failures so that would be
something that's tested in an animal
that works and then fails in a human
clinical drug trial 50% of those
failures can be attributed to poorly
selected animal models and so I think
part of where we we will be getting
traction is picking you know developing
sophisticated models as a sort of point
of entry into being able to understand
some of these things that are really
difficult us studying people yeah such a
key point and um for those that um have
not heard of pre-clinical models
pre-clinical models are non-human models
so it could be Mouse could be nonhuman
primate could be flies or worms for that
matter but uh we're going to talk a lot
about non-human primate preclinical
models um and the work that you've been
doing and of course also the work that
you've been doing in humans um the other
animal um the other private the other
primate right exactly I love to remind
people that we're primates um Old World
primates um thank you for doing that so
you've been talking about the genetic
influences on autism and of course genes
in the environment interact right it's
never nature or nurture it's always an
interaction and that isn't just about
the epig genome it's also just about the
fact that nature impacts the genome and
our genome impacts the way that we
interact with the environment Etc so
what is the role of the environment in
autism both the frequency and the
presentation of autism right so I mean
there are again lots of different
epidemiological studies so um Advanced
parental age uh prematurity severe
prematurity is a risk factor for autism
um maternal illness during pregnancy um
so there's there's a bunch of different
things that have been associated with an
increased risk for autism in terms of
environmental influences and how they
can intersect with Biology um one of the
things that I was really struck by in
the early 2000s that at least by my read
of the literature hasn't really gone
anywhere was this idea that was proposed
by pashco who used to run the
neurobiology department um at Yale um
expert in brain neuro anatomy in
non-human primates and in humans
embryology um really luminary of our
field and he had a series of papers
exploring how the migration of neurons
during early development you know it's
you and I both know but most people out
there probably don't know because we
haven't covered this in the podcast um
it's not typical dinner table
conversation you know when you when an
embryo when a human embryo is developing
the the neurons are born at one location
and they migrate out some distance to
their final um resting place where then
they grow out their connections and
connect with one another and that
process of neuron neuronal migration is
oh so critical for the eventual wiring
of the brain and rakes had this idea
that perhaps and I really want to
emphasize perhaps that the more frequent
incidents of autism might be correlated
with the increase in early prenatal
ultrasound and he had these papers
published in number of really
high-profile journals including
proceedings of the National Academy and
Science and elsewhere showing that in a
mouse model if you do
Ultrasound with each successive
ultrasound you got more migration errors
right so there to me was a you know an
interesting example of of the
environment frequency of ultrasound and
cell migration having some sort of
interaction but it seemed like it never
went anywhere it never got tacked to
okay you should keep in mind the number
of ultrasounds that you're getting for
your child and of course ultrasounds are
critical for for pregnant women to get
because they can Stave off a number of
developmental issues and they're super
important but you know we've heard about
ultrasound you know it within the
scientific literature and then
occasionally we'll hear other theories
about okay it's having two parents who
are both engineers and then we'll hear
oh you know it's um you know toxicity in
the food environment we've heard you
know hypothesis about vaccines or the
the adant that the vaccines are
contained in you know in that large
cloud of the
has anything really um emerged from them
as like okay there really seems to be at
least one major risk factor
environmental risk factor because I feel
like all those theories I come up get
some popular press bunch of papers are
published sometimes those papers are
retracted like in the case of the
vaccines um and then the theory kind of
dies yeah so is there any specific
environmental influence on autism that
we can say yes they're really seems to
be something there yeah I I mean it's a
it's a really spectacularly good
question I think the tricky part about
it is that every single person that
comes into a trial has a different
genetic background right and so until we
can have these a priori stratified
trials where you could then you know as
a good scientist you would only
manipulate maybe one two variables at a
time right but when you're doing these
large epidemiological studies because
you can't it's very difficult to do
experimental studies right especially
with developing children um I think
that's an incredibly difficult study to
do right so there's been an interest in
this field of there's these neurogenetic
syndromes that have high penetrance for
autism which basically means that you
could have a disorder um or you know
another genetic condition let's say it
doesn't have to be a single Gene but
that a lot of those kids tend to also
get an Autism diagnosis and so there's
been work and like so for instance
fragile X is a good example where
because autism is so diverse in terms of
clinical presentation that let's say you
have a medication that could work for a
handful of kids in the trial you may not
be statistically powered to see it right
so so you know the way I think about the
autism world is there's so little we
don't know so think about being in a
dark room and you have a flashlight and
you only see where you shine the light
right and so if you think about a very
heterogeneous genetic heterogeneous
study it's going to be very difficult to
tease out these pieces because an
environmental risk factor um might be a
driver for one kid but not another right
and so I think what we need to do is to
have these genetically defined subgroups
of individuals and then be able to test
the G by Gene by environment
interactions or in this genetically
defined group of individuals um can we
test this certain medication to see if
it's beneficial for this subgroup of
children got it so you you mentioned
fragile X which um we know um presents
with autism like symptoms in some cases
and then I think of another disease like
um Timothy syndrome a mutation in an L
Type calcium channel which um for those
of you that don't know what these cell
type calcium channels are they're
they're not just important for the
function of neurons in the brain they're
really important for the function of
neurons and other other tissues
including heart tissue right so um kids
with Timothy Syndrome have cardiac
issues yeah and they have autism so you
know I think it's important for us to
kind of explore this a bit because in
most people's minds you know kids with
autism have autism and occasionally
they'll have other issues you know gut
issues or heart issues or um muscular
skeletal issues but we often think that
that's the consequence of the autism but
often times that they have multiple
things going on and the autism actually
could be secondary or independent of the
other thing that's going on so this is
what leads me back to this idea of a
spectrum you know is you know is it
possible that what we call autism is
actually like 50 different disorders or
50 different conditions depending on
what one wants to call them um I mean
what is autism really I mean is it it's
what does it really center around what
and I I think here maybe it's useful to
go like do we go to the diagnostic
criteria like how do we decide if a
child has autism if they also have a
bunch of other things that are
challenging them I I think that that's
The $64,000 Question right and and and
again in other areas of medicine so if
you think about let's think about cancer
biology right like decades ago somebody
would come in with cancer and you would
hit them with radiation chemotherapy and
that was the best that we could do right
but with the invention of a lot of
molecular tools you can remove a a tumor
and you can do molecular profiling and
even you know have personalized
medications made right to attack that t
tumor and so you know know what's really
tricky when you have a behavioral
diagnosis that's not
biologically defined you you see a lot
of heterogeneity so it's incredibly
difficult I think to answer this
question because we don't know how many
kinds of
autismsocial people people I've heard
clinicians say well that's not really
autism right that's a piece of fragile X
right but if it's a behavioral diagnosis
and they meet be behavioral criteria it
becomes this weird circular argument
right so like until we really understand
what autism is I I I think that it's
going to be very tricky to start you
know
subing different aspects of the
condition as we all know quality
nutrition influences of course our
physical health but also our mental
health and our cognitive functioning our
memory our ability to learn new things
and to focus and we know that one of the
most important features of highquality
nutrition is making sure that we get
enough vitamins and minerals from
highquality unprocessed or minimally
processed sources as well as enough
probiotics and prebiotics and fiber to
support basically all the cellular
functions in our body including the gut
microbiome now I like most everybody try
to get optimal nutrition from Whole
Foods ideally mostly from minimally
processed or nonprocessed Foods however
one of the challenges that I and so many
other people face is getting enough
servings of high quality fruits and
vegetables per day as well as fiber and
probiotics that often accompany those
fruits and vegetables that's why way
back in 2012 long before I ever had a
podcast I started drinking ag1 and so
I'm delighted that ag1 is sponsoring the
hubman Lab podcast the reason I started
taking ag1 and the reason I still drink
ag1 once or twice a day is that it
provides all of my foundational
nutritional needs that is it provides
insurance that I get the proper amounts
of those vitamins minerals probiotics
and fiber to ensure optimal mental
health physical health and performance
if you'd like to try ag1 you can go to
drink a1.com huberman to claim a special
offer they're giving away five free
travel packs plus a year supply of
vitamin D3 K2 again that's drink a1.com
huberman to claim that special offer
well probably a good time for us to
think about the work that you've done in
terms of trying to tack the biology of
social
communication and behavior yeah right
those things interact not just language
but also Behavior to autism in humans
using non-human primate models and then
of course to also discuss some of the
work that you've been doing in humans
and we can't have that discussion
without first having a discussion about
two neuropeptides that I think most
people have heard of at least one of
them and I think there's a lot of
misunderstanding about but you're going
to clarify that for us which are
oxytocin and vasopressin so before we
dive into the uh the important work that
you've been doing on vasopressin in
particular but also oxytocin and
autism what are oxytocin and vasopress
really okay so they're these small
little peptide they're nine amino acids
long are very tiny they only differ by
two amino acids and they're these
ancient peptides that are hundreds of
millions of years old and in almost any
species studied um whether it's the
current version you might have vasit
tocin or other Mosin which are um sort
of precursor forms in other species but
they're highly evolutionarily conserved
and they're involved in social behavior
um in pretty much any it could be egg
laying it could be you know but but
reproduction and social behavior across
the philogenetic tax so house cats make
vasopressin and oxytocin humans
obviously make vasopressin and oxytocin
and pretty much every other species that
has to interact with and connect with
other members of its species especially
mammals right so oxytocin and vasor
pressin are pervasive and Maman species
do the different species tend to make
oxytocin and vasopressin in similar
brain areas and tissues um yes but not
completely overlapping but I I think the
thing that the the beautiful mystery
about these and the infuriating piece of
them is that because they're so
structurally similar um they can have
similar effects and they there's four
receptors that they bind to so if you
think about a hormone or a
neurotransmitter so oxytocin vasor
pressent if you think about them like a
key and a receptor like a lock and you
have to put them together to open a door
open Behavior they can bind to these
four receptors so it can be very
difficult to
disentangle which one is acting and at
which receptor and where in the brain oh
so oxytocin vasopressin are chemically
similar yes interesting yes and uh where
would you say lies their greatest um
output Divergence which is just nerd
speak for um is there an example of
something that oxytocin does that
vasopressin doesn't and vice versa yeah
okay so what's really fascinating is
these two neurotransmitters or hormones
were discovered for their peripheral
effects which basically means not in
their brain but somewhere in their body
and so oxytocin's involved in um uterine
contractions and milk let down and so
was during lactation so people sort of
always thought of it as the female
hormone and then vasopress has um at
least in the in the peripheral system
has been involved in um urine regul like
urinary output regulation blood pressure
um and so we only knew about their their
physiological roles as their sort of
classic hormones for decades and what
was interesting is these um like naming
conventions are fascinating medicine
right so you could name a virus after
where it was first found right or it
could be named after somebody who
discovered the disease like Alzheimer's
for instance is a good example and what
was interesting oxytocin was only named
once vasor pressin was named twice so
it's either called Arginine vasor
pressin or anti-diuretic hormone and so
it had two different names and so as you
can imagine sometimes genes are named
twice and so somebody in cancer is
studying one Gene and somebody and
autism is studying another and they're
not even communicating because they
don't even realize that they've at least
historically now we have all kinds of
Gene annotation sites so it's less
likely to happen now but but what was
fascinating is they were these hormones
were named oxytocin is Greek for quick
birth so for decades people only
appreciated their physiological roles
but but there were neuron anatomist
saying hey so these are both made
they're made in a lot of different
places but the the the action sort of
happens in the hypothalamus where
they're made and there were anatomists
that said wait these sort of project
back into the brain what are these doing
in the brain and one of my favorite
historical stories was um I had a mentor
um uh a colleague like an you know who I
didn't train with but he was um a real
source of wisdom to me for many years
and his name is Court Peterson and he
told me this wonderful story about this
duuk oologist named Peter claer and um
Peter was studying ulet so sheep and
goats and he wrote a story of paper in
1971 called Mother Love what turns it on
and um you know one thing about science
is I love going back and seeing where do
the Pearls of Wisdom come from and so he
wrote this and said you know oxytocin is
orchestrating all these events of
motherhood and there are sheep and goats
in particular that have offspring that
are precocious meaning they're basically
born ready you know within an hour they
can run with the herd unlike our species
which is altricial meaning we have very
helpless infants and mom needs to bond
really quickly with that baby if it's
going to be running around and you only
you know from an evolutionary
perspective you want to be investing in
the baby that's yours not somebody
else's right and um he hypothesized that
it was oxytocin that was being
co-released into the brain and during
milk let down that was what turned
Mother Love on and that was really the
beginning of this whole field of
thinking and so that opened up thinking
about oxytocin in rodent maternal care
and a variety of other instances can I
just briefly interrupt you because I
find this so interesting and I know it's
interesting to everyone listening as
well because you know yes and thank you
for making it clear that oxid doin has
many different roles um but this role of
Mother Love and bonding to infant um has
me needing to ask whether or not the
idea was that oxytocin is released in
the mother when she interacts with her
own baby um and that leads me to the
question is oxytocin also released in
the baby um in reaction to to the mother
and how long is that effect lasting
because in order to have a pervasive
bond with that baby and not just some
other baby and of course we still have
visual cues and you know we know our
baby versus another baby most instances
um there are rare exceptions or perhaps
not so rare exceptions but leaving those
aside you
know the mechanism that would allow for
mother infant bonding and infant mother
bonding by way of oxytocin presumably is
something that is literally changing
their brains saying it's you are the are
the center of my life right and the baby
of course is saying well you are my life
because you are the source of life right
certainly for the early part um early
part of life and that nowadays it seems
that that that can extend well into the
uh the teens and 20s for some people but
um you how how is oxytocin working is it
is it working over the course of minutes
hours is there some specificity of this
baby and this mom that links them in in
some more pervasive way I mean how is
oxytocin doing this magic of bonding
yeah I mean it's it's very species
specific right so I think that and you
need to think about like The
evolutionary history of the species
right so if you think about sheep or
goats the early studies that were done
are you um The Passage through the
vaginal Canal was what you know so you
would activate oxytocin receptors that
way but if you gave an oxytocin
antagonist meaning you would give into
the brain something that blocked the
oxytocin receptors so if the oxytocin is
being released into the BL brain but you
have a pharmacological agent blocking
its ability to bind to its receptors
these sheep and goats wouldn't um bond
to their baby for instance so literally
the passage of the baby out of the
vaginal Canal triggers the oxytocin
pathway the release of oxytocin as in
lactation does too nature is so
beautiful because if you had to pick one
event yeah to trigger the release of
oxytocin if oxytocin's role is to create
bonding with offspring that would be the
event because that's a tough one to
mistake right right but but what I will
say because I think you will you know to
avoid you getting attacked on Twitter or
wherever you might I'm GNA get attacked
anyway if not if not for this discussion
then another one but I'm tougher than I
like so um but it's really species
specific right so if you think about our
species and a lot of primate species we
live in these extended family groups and
that's how we evolved and so unlike a
goat or a sheep that might live in a
herd where there's a lot of
non-relatives we lived in a community of
relatives right and so we and we do all
kinds of care of extended relatives and
so you wouldn't necessarily expect in a
primate species where you have this long
rearing history where help from the
family and and biparental care where
where sort of everybody sort of like it
takes a village to raise the baby we
readily adopt in our in primate
societies right and so you know um like
I had a CE I mean I'll tell you
something personal I had a C-section um
and uh had I had a lot of postpartum
complications and so lactation didn't
work out that well for me one of my
friends would say um I massive um DVS
and Pulmonary emop and so I almost died
after my son was born the first time and
so I didn't have a vaginal delivery I
couldn't
DVT thrombosis yeah and it was sort of
like welcome to Motherhood and I was in
the ICU and um had to get a filter put
in um an inferior vnea filter to um stop
me from dying because the I had
scattershot clots all over my lungs and
so I didn't really you know I didn't I I
didn't do a vaginal delivery I had a
C-section and I wasn't really able to
lactate and man I love that baby right
so you know I can give you know what I
will say is um it's really different in
primates and we don't really understand
how bonding occurs but what I will say
is that bonding between a mother you
really need to think about the
evolutionary selective pressure so I was
an evolutionary biologist before I found
Neuroscience right and so I really
everything I do I think about from an
evolutionary perspective um so but it it
is um many people go into the oxytocin V
oppressing field because they have a lot
of questions about social interactions
right like I think if you think about us
is being social is actually one of the
one of the core characteristics of our
species right so social interactions are
rewarding from infancy they Keep Us
Alive as you mentioned right and so I
think it's not an accident that the way
we think about disorder in our species
is many disorders are disorders because
of lack of social connectedness right so
it could be something like autism where
you know there's these pervasive social
interaction impairments it could be
something like drug abuse where you know
you you a risk factor for drug abuse is
feeling you know socially disconnected
and alone right um social um isolation
or loss of a loved one is a very strong
predictor of the onset of a stress
related depressive anxiety disorder in
terms of when and how oxytocin is
released you mentioned um mother infant
bonding um I think you said yes that the
infant is also releasing oxytocin we
think um so it's it's bidirectional um
we think I think most of the work has
been done in mom would be and and again
this has not been really done well in
primates right so we're extrapolating
this information from species that have
different evolutionary histories than us
right so it's go sheeps um Prairie vs
mice rats so what do we know about the
role of oxytocin in humans do I mean we
know it's there yeah we presume based on
the animal models that it's involved in
mother infant bonding um and presumably
romantic partner bonding at least you
hear that a lot um it was unfortunately
nicknamed The Love hormone yes um and
the reason it's unfortunate it was is
that while that might cue attention to
oxytocin and I'm you know a big fan of
people paying attention to biological
phenomena it uh it discards the other
and many roles of of oxytocin but yeah
what can we say about oxytocin in humans
if anything like do we know that it does
I mean we're just so we're assuming
based on the animal models that it does
something I mean this is very different
than like dopamine where there's tons of
animal model data but we know but they
brain Imaging where we know where
dopamine is expressed and do we even
know where oxytocin receptors are
expressed in the human brain presumably
that information is is out there
recently but again there's a lot of
specificity and I think if you're
thinking about disorders you would then
have to study those specific
subpopulations right and and you need
you know a lot of this work has been
done so you have to think about how do
we study it right so the best way to
study it would be to have radio tracers
where you could then which we do have
for dopamine and and other compounds
where you would then go and see where
after somebody's performed a task do we
see you know um activation right or
uptake um there are some Imaging studies
they're usually done giving intranasal
oxytocin um and then you basically ask
questions about okay we give you
oxytocin and trenas which presumably
enters the brain there's we could talk
about reasons why we think that um and
then we have you perform on some task
right and so you know there's evidence
if you give oxytocin it diminishes the
amygdala's response um to fearful
stimuli right so that it might have this
sort of pro-social effect and and it was
actually data like that that caused
people to start thinking um initially
about oxytocin and those are data on
humans that's right it reminds me that
there was this brief moment where
oxytocin wasn't just being discussed as
the love hormone it it was being
discussed as the trust hormon right also
um far too simple heuristic but but
again I think it's cool that the you
know that the the Press picks up on
these things and at least tells people
about what's being discovered and we
just always have to be careful that not
um uh have it leads the assumption that
that's the only role of a given of a
given hormone so um it can reduce
apparently it can reduce the output of
the amydala in some way this brain area
associated with um threat detection um
and so you could imagine how that would
bias the person toward being more
pro-social right um have there been
studies exploring the role of oxytocin
in making autistic children more
pro-social and behind that question I
suppose is the assump you can verify or
or not that autistic children are less
pro-social than other children um is
that true um or is it that you know
autistic kids are just maybe more
pro-social with the one friend they
really really like um I happen to know
some kids uh with autism or however you
want to phrase it and um they have close
friends and they seem to really like
those specific friends a lot like they
seem very happy when they show up at the
door and like all all the Hallmarks of
you know healthy social mind but it is
true that they are uncomfortable in in
groups and where there's a lot of noise
a busy birthday party is overwhelming
for them but you see them playing with
one or two friends and like you could
see all that and assume okay it's just
kind of an introverted kid actually kind
of reminds me of me you know I mean I
don't have a problem with crowds but I I
much prefer to be with a small group of
friends or one close friend so I hear
you I'm that way too right so um you
know how do we think about this um okay
well I would say the social features of
autism are interesting right and so you
might have there were there was an
attempt a long time ago like 1979
there's a woman named Lura Wing who
tried to subtype the social features of
autism right and so there could be
people um that are socially avoidant and
really just don't want to have social
interactions there could be kids that
are um active but odd which means that
they have an interest in being social
but maybe they don't read social cues
right and they interact in ways that
other kids don't understand or make
could cause bullying right and sounds
like Junior High School yeah exactly um
and and that's often why um you know
some autistic kids do better with adults
right because adults know how to sort of
Channel um discussions with somebody who
might be a little socially awkward right
but there's different phenotypes I mean
uh people having a disinterest in social
interactions could be that they're
highly socially anxious right um that
making eye contact makes them anxious
you again that's another caveat um there
have been some studies administering
oxytocin to individuals with autism and
again these are these single dose
studies so the first studies that were
were done were looking at single dose
oxytocin in males because some of the
and we can talk a little bit about why
oxytocin versus vasopressin which
vasopressin actually would have been my
choice um based on the animal literature
and we can talk about that but vas
oxytocin was given to males um partly
because it wouldn't the idea would be
that the of Target effects in the
peripheral nervous system I.E milk let
down uterine contraction are not going
to happen in males right and so that it
was deemed that they might be safer
subjects males are often also the the
go-to for research studies as you may
have talked about on on your podcast
before too something that fortunately is
changing thanks to a mandate by the uh
by the NIH correct um I I had to just
kind of um smile slash um raise my
eyebrows a little bit at the idea that
you know the the assumption that
oxytocin administered to males yes one
can see why it wouldn't cause milk down
or uterine contract
but um but of there could be other
peripheral effects ofto and males but
they had to pick they had to pick one so
they went with males okay so um and
there is this higher incidence of autism
in males so it's not a terrible place to
start you just would hope that they
would also do the the experiment on
females but um so they're doing this by
nasal spray so intranasal one dose
correct and for reasons that I don't
understand it's 24 international units
and I think maybe somebody did the first
study using it and you know this is how
science happens right and it worked and
so then everyone uses that protocol and
so then there's been a lot of studies
looking at um you know there's one
reading the mind and the eyes so can you
look at pictures of somebody's eyes and
then ask what is the emotion that
they're feeling right after receiving
this or Placebo um where's your eye gaze
going in a picture right so one of one
of the theories is that people with
Autism May at least a subset of them
lack social motivation so maybe they're
not looking in the places like eyes
where you rece receive a lot of social
cues that are relevant to social
communication and so some of these early
studies showed that a single dose of
oxytocin in people that were um had high
functioning autism so they were verbal
like you said they could come in for
studies and that it looked like it had
some potential Effectiveness and so
there became a really strong interest in
the field to think about oxytocin
potentially is a therapy for autism and
is oxytocin available over the counter
does it require prescription I I mean
you see sites that are selling it but
that doesn't mean anything these days
right um there's gry Market there's all
sorts of stuff going on um but I know
people that have used oxytocin um
there's actually a market for and by the
way folks I'm not suggesting this but
someone the other day told me that
they've been regularly taking um uh
oxytocin ketamine nasal inhalations um
as part of their work with their
licensed therapist on um like PTSD type
stuff relating to let's just call it
relational trauma okay um so that's
happening um but let's just think about
oxytocin alone for the moment um are
parents of of autistic kids able to like
buy oxytocin nasal spray no so so it
would need to be written like the
prescription would be need to be written
by a um by a physician um and it's not
on the market right so there's one thing
we should say is there's only two drugs
that are approved by the FDA to treat
autism and they're both antis psychotics
which they um they treat Associated
features like irritability and they have
off Target effects like weight gain and
and and you know so we don't have any
medications that are currently approved
in the US or anywhere else for that
matter to treat the core features of
autism interesting and um unfortunate um
and hopefully that will change in the
not too distant future um do we know
that children autism people with Autism
because I'm going to just sort of assume
that um autism is stable over the
lifespan um like if a child is diagnosed
with autism are they going to be an
adolescent and adult with autism so I
would say that in a lot of cases autism
has lifelong impact but there are people
who outgrow their diagnosis um you know
there are people who respond well to
behavioral therapy um I mean obviously
it's not the Cure All for everybody
there's lots of people who go through
intensive behavioral therapy and
probably see minimal benefits um but I
mean it's certainly something that
occurs in childhood for the diagnosis
occurs in childhood and it you know for
most people will then be present across
the lifespan so we could say people with
Autism because each study sometimes
we'll have adults sometimes you'll have
teenagers sometimes you'll have
kids I'd like to take a quick break and
thank our sponsor insid tracker insid
tracker is a personalized nutrition
platform that analyzes data from your
blood and DNA to help you better
understand your body and help you reach
your health goals now I've long been a
believer in getting regular blood work
done for the simple reason that many of
the factors that impact your immediate
and long-term Health can only be
analyzed from a quality blood test a
major problem with a lot of blood tests
out there however is that you get
information back about metabolic factors
lipids and hormones and so forth but you
don't know what to do with that
information with inside tracker they
make it very easy because they have a
personalized platform that allows you to
see the levels of all those things
metabolic factors lipids hormones Etc
but it gives you specific directives
that you can follow that relate to
nutrition behavioral modifications
supplements Etc that can help you bring
those numbers into the ranges that are
optimal for you if you'd like to try
insid tracker you can go to insid
tracker.com huberman to get 20% off any
of insid tracker's plans again that's
insid
tracker.com
huberman is it known whether or not
people with Autism assuming they meet
the criteria for being autistic at that
at that moment um have lower natural
circulating or active levels of oxytocin
because you know it's one thing for a
nasal spray to um of oxytocin to improve
social functioning it's another um to
know that it that the effect is
addressing an underlying biological
deficit yeah that's it's such a great
question okay so we should unpack that
because there's been a lot of work in
this area so the first question is where
are we measuring the oxytocin right so
we mentioned oxytocin has all kinds of
effect in the body as well as the brain
and it's released into the blood but
it's also released directly into the
brain and there's variable evidence
about if you measure it in blood is it a
readout of the brain or not right or
should you be looking at something like
spinal fluid that's maybe a a better
biochemical proxy of the brain um most
studies so what I will say is there were
there's been m a handful of small
studies where there has been some you
know there's been some benefit Maybe no
benefit small effects we did a study
that was a small study at Stamford and
it was based on um Mouse genetic data
and I'll I'll sort of walk you through
what we did um so there's multiple Mouse
models of these neurogenetic syndromes
where um people have social impairment
right we can Qui quibble about whether
that's autism or not but that they have
social impairment and so that there are
this um fragile X Mouse there's a PR
willly syndrome Mouse which is the
magile 2 Gene that um gets manipulated
and then there's a catnap two mouse and
in all of those instances when you
genetically modify those mice you see a
reduction of oxytocin in the
hypothalamus and what's interesting is
that um in those instances where you see
this genetic modification you do see
lower blood levels in these genetically
defined models what's really cool is you
can give oxytocin across development in
those models and at least in the cat to
Mouse you can restore oxytocin neuron
number to equivalent of control animals
suggesting that oxytocin is doing
something in these oxytocin deficient
animals right so these are not an
oxytocin Gene manipulation but these are
these syndromes where you see as a
consequence of manipulating genes for
these syndromes that oxytocin gets
knocked down right and so our thinking
when we went into our clinical trial was
what if um its blood oxytocin levels
that there going to be a subset of
individuals that just make less oxytocin
humans and that maybe those are the
individuals who could who stand to
benefit the most from treatment and so
we were the first group um to
ask you know across this range of
individuals who showed up and we did in
all the trials that we'll talk about
today um these are done with my
colleague Antonio Harden at Stanford
who's a child psychiatrist um and we
always have double blind meaning that
the investigative team is blind and that
the um or unaware I should say they're
unaware of treatment and then the
families and the children are unaware um
and then they're randomized meaning
there's an equal chance you could get
either drug or Placebo um and they're
and they're controlled right okay so we
asked if we know what your pre
pre-treatment pre-treatment blood
oxytocin level is who's going to benefit
from treatment and we found a couple
really interesting things one was that
the lower your Baseline so your
pre-treatment blood oxytocin level you
showed much greater benefit from the
oxytocin intervention these are children
one one intervention one nasal spray
this was four weeks sorry I should have
clarified this is four weeks of
treatment being um administered oxytocin
twice a day okay and um and and so we
saw Effectiveness there may sorry to
interrupt so much but just uh males male
and female subjects we did but again you
know because the autism is male biased
and prevalence even if you make this
heroic effort to over recruit try to get
more girls in and um in in the study we
usually try to aim for the prevalence
rate because it's difficult to get girls
just because there's fewer of them got
it okay but um boys and girls were
included they're taking oxytocin over
the period of several four weeks and if
they started off with lower Baseline
levels of oxytocin you observed a
benefit of the oxytocin treatment in
those individuals what about the
individuals who had normal to high you
didn't see much benefit right and so
that was a a cue to me to think that
there may be a subset of individuals
that you know for whatever reason they
have lower oxytocin and they may stand
to benefit more from treatment and none
of the prior studies had looked at blood
oxytocin levels and so what we had
thought was that well maybe if everybody
had measured Baseline blood oxytocin
levels maybe some of these you know
maybe there would have been more um
positive outcomes so but there's there's
a lot of controversy in this field about
whether oxytocin is a treatment for
autism right so after we completed that
trial there was a large
multi-site um what's called a phase
three oxytocin treatment trial that was
done at I think five sites and they gave
oxytocin for an extended period of time
um and they showed no benefit um and and
were they looking to see who started off
with low levels of oxytocin at
pre-treatment so what was interesting
about that study um and there were a lot
of issues with it
was that um oxytocin is something where
you have to if you look at it it
degrades it's like that's kind of what I
joke about right so you need to take it
we take when we go in we have like these
really intense protocols right so you go
in and we have vacutainer tubes that are
cold and we put them on ice and then the
FLOTUS takes the blood from the child a
lot of technical gymastics yeah and then
we make sure we spin it in a centrifuge
cold and then we pipe head it onto dry
eyes so like so we have very minimal
loss of the signal and so if you don't
adhere to those rigid protocols which is
very difficult to do across multiple
sites um it can be very difficult to get
an accurate read of oxytocin and so I
think for me it's still an open question
um they didn't see that blood oxytocin
predicted response um in that study um
the data weren't provided in the paper
it was just said that they didn't um but
it's still an open question
and so that you know maybe that is the
way if you give it acutely like in those
early studies we talked about that maybe
oxytocin you know diminishes Spar we
know that oxytocin decreases um the
stress axis the hypothalamic pituitary
um adrenal axis and then it can diminish
anxiety in animal models so we that's
well established um and in a former life
I was a stress researcher so I've spent
a lot of time thinking about this but
but it's sort of the sad thing is is
that once you have a negative trial it
um there isn't a lot of interest in
funding uh the work going forward right
and so I think it's still really an open
question about if there is a subset of
individuals that could benefit from
oxytocin replacement therapy right and
it's and and until there's money to do
that work um we may not ever know the
answer well be it will be important for
that work to be done eventually
hopefully the field will return to it
despite whatever Trends might be
happening now I think it's important to
know for the parents of autistic
children um whether or not there were
any negative effects of oxytocin
Administration in particular in the
children that did not benefit from
oxytocin treatment the rationale is the
following well of course these things
require a prescription um if a parent
has a child with autism especially if
they're young enough that the behavioral
interventions could possibly stand a
good chance of inducing neuroplasticity
rewiring of the neural circuits that
underly social connection well then
there's this um Tim limited window um in
which you know those parents presumably
are willing to try most anything
provided it's safe right so let's assume
and I'm making up these numbers now
because I haven't seen this study but
according to what you told me that let's
say a third of the autistic boys and
girls that come in have um low Baseline
levels of oxytocin they're the ones that
are going to benefit from this oxytocin
intervention the other 23ds don't well
given the difficulties of measuring
Baseline levels of oxytocin most people
don't have access to those kind of
resources um if it's safe to give
oxytocin no matter what well then if I
were that parent I'd be knocking on my
Physician's door saying hey give me an
oxytocin spray because my kid might fall
into that onethird category if and only
if it turns out that oxytocin is safe to
give but if there's a risk profile that
doesn't justify that kind of shotgun
approach well then I wouldn't do that
yeah so um is oxytocin spray safe and if
so why doesn't every physician who has a
patient with autism give them oxytocin
nasal spray right it's a great question
and I I know that you know I'm a parent
of three children and I know this sense
of like you would do anything to help
your child right and so I I think the
tricky part is that so one thing I will
say is that all of the studies and
there's been many of them have shown
that oxytocin is um is relatively safe
in a pediatric population right um the
tricky part is I don't know there's
Physicians that you know really pay
attention to clinical trials and if they
don't see a benefit they may not be
willing to write the prescription right
so until we could identify a group of
children that could benefit you know we
need to create the opportunity for
Physicians to recognize that this could
potentially still be a treatment right
but that work you know but I I think the
tricky part and what I will say is and
we can maybe talk a bit about vasor
press which you know my feeling is that
if I was placing bets and and having to
choose between these two my my money
would be on vasor press well we are
definitely going to yeah um talk about
Vaso pressent in detail I mean the
reason I I mentioned that hypothetical
scenario is just the sense of urgency
and in some cases desperation that
parents feel and you know time's ticking
and if oxytocin's safe then you know um
I guess I'll put in my vote that you
know parents should at least talk to
their physician maybe even hand them the
study um to consider but I can also
understand the perspective of a
pediatrician who says well listen it was
a small number of kids that benefited um
you're welcome to try it but I don't you
know it doesn't seem like the results
are that impressive but um you this gets
to a bunch of larger issues about you
know Medical Care and randomized control
trials and the desperation of parents
and kids to treat neurodevelopmental
challenges um I I just want to ask
because it feels relevant in a in a real
way um you know if ultimately the goal
of improving symptom profiles in
autistic kids is about improving social
cognition and social
behavior and that process involves
rewiring of brain circuits
neuroplasticity is there any reason
reason to think that other approaches to
inducing neuroplasticity would be
beneficial even if they're not in the
biological Pathways that are disrupted
in autism um I think for instance about
the now extensive use of ssris for the
treatment of
depression some cases it works in some
cases it doesn't side effect profiles
are a serious concern yeah as I've
discussed on this podcast before but
ultimately we know that depression is
not a serotonin deficiency in most cases
ssris or atypical anti-depressants like
Ryon Wellbutrin and things of that sort
when they work they probably work
because of their ability to induce neuro
or assist neuroplasticity right right um
also the trials on psilocybin are not
really about psilocybin they're about
neuroplasticity at least the trials for
depression right there may be other uses
of psilocybin that relate more directly
to the effects of psilocybin But
ultimately you know what we're talking
about here is the attempt to re wire the
brain in a specific way whether or not
it's assisted by oxytocin or some other
mechanism so the question is are there
trials happening where people are
exploring say psilocybin MDMA which by
the way we know increases oxytocin and
serotonin dramatically as well as um
things like atypical anti-depressants in
kids that have autism not because we
think that those autistic kids are
deficient in any of the neurochemical
that these drugs would Target but that
these drugs can help rewire the brain
and ultimately that's what these kids
need right I it's a really great point
and I there might be subsets of kids
right there might be kids where there
would be a medication that would Target
other Pathways but that potently
releases oxytocin right that and but
there might be kids that have an
oxytocin deficiency right but I think
that that circles back to your point at
the beginning or our point is that
autism is a very heterogeneous condition
and being a
to know before you begin a trial right
like who am I going to put into it and
what is my primary outcome like one
measure that I think is going to move
the needle right like it kind of
requires a crystal ball so there's a lot
of guesswork that goes into this um but
I would very much like to see I I will
say one other thing that um there I have
a colleague named Adam guella who's at
the University of Sydney and he
published a paper a year or two ago now
suggesting that oxytocin be may be most
effective in kids at younger ages and I
I don't quote me somewhere between two
and or you know two and five or three
and six or something find the paper and
put it in the show show notes but you
know so it could be to your point about
neuroplasticity that oxytocin may be
maximally beneficial in younger ages
right and if you're if these studies are
these Haj podes across ages and across
sort of different social
phenotypes finding that signal is really
important right and and maybe age is a
driver or or maybe you know low blood
oxytocin regardless of what age you are
or maybe in Adam's case if you recruit
really young children you're likely to
see a benefit just because the BL the
brain is wiring up and it's more plastic
at you know younger ages yeah that's
also a vote um in my opinion um for
early examination of kids right like
parents really need to get autism screen
and perhaps maybe the most important
thing is to make autism screening as
available and as inexpensive as possible
for everyone because of the importance
of early intervention even if it's
purely behavioral intervention but
certainly if it's behavioral and Drug
intervention but the clinic wait times
are really long right so you have to
have a specialist who's capable to
diagnose autism and so you could have a
clinic where you know you're showing
Troublesome features and a parent wants
to get their kid into a clinic and you
could have a 12mth or or 18-month wait
time right and so there are a lot of
people that are thinking about are there
are there laboratory based tests that we
can develop maybe either for detection
or clinical referral right so could we
come up with a a biomarker panel for
instance where we might be able to say
wow here's some here's a panel where we
think this child is at reasonable risk
for developing autism can we make sure
they're prioritized for getting a
diagnosis right so we can get them an an
early intervention but right now we
don't we don't have that right so having
some sort of laboratory based test
whether it could be
biological um or if we could do
something with ey gaze and there's a lot
of companies working on these things now
to say this may not you know and and
also obviously again autism is always
controversial in this field right
there's so many different stakeholders a
lot of clinicians will say well I don't
I don't want a 30-second video clip
replacing expert clinical opinion
there's good reasons for them to feel
that way but I think if there was a way
to prioritize people that are in this
line um you know we could get diagnoses
faster well you wouldn't want false
positives but I would think that a 30
second video clip provided itself
something useful is going to be more
valuable than nothing yeah given the
time sensitivity uh what are some of the
barriers to um getting this behavioral
testing to be not just more prominent
but pervasive like it seems to me that
well I recall in school they gave us the
hearing test we all marched on the bus
we get the beep test and you know um you
know for hearing um challenges uh we get
Vision tests you get the babinsky reflex
test not the moment you come out of the
womb but pretty pretty soon after I mean
why isn't this stuff um happening uh for
autism um for every kid yeah it's not
scalable right so you these interviews
with parents and the tests that you do
can take hours right and and any given
clinician even if they're working really
long hours there just aren't that many
people that are have the extensive
training needed to make these expert
diagnoses right and so I think that
there's you know clinicians that are
doing the absolute best they can but
they can only see a certain number of of
people a week right and does it have to
be a physician sorry to interrupt does
it or could it could you know could a
well trained technician do this yeah
well I mean I I think technically it's a
DSM diagnos is right so it's usually
somebody who has a clinical degree so it
would be a clinical psychologist it
could be a behavioral pediatrician it
could be you know a child psychiatrist
or child neurologist but I mean again
that requires years and years of
training um and if we look in areas
where people have fewer accesses access
to Resource I mean particularly in
impoverished areas the mean age of an
Autism diagnosis is years later than in
wealthy areas where you know there's
many different medical specialist with
parents you know that aren't working
three jobs and you know can sit waiting
around you know and and really Lobby and
and really advocate for their kids right
because you know if they don't show up
for work that day they're not going to
get fired from their job right and so I
think that you know if there's some sort
of solution that allows there to be a
more democratic approach to saying we
need a really quick way like you said to
be able to identify at risk children
especially if it's a a blood test or
something like that you know it could be
incredibly
impactful are there human trials
exploring MDMA methylene dioxy
methamphetamine also referred to as
ecstasy um and oryan for um treatment of
autism so I was aware that Maps had an
MDMA trial in autism um I don't know
what's happened with that yeah perhaps
it's still ongoing I'll check the map
site in communication with them from
time to time I mean the the the reason
for asking it of course you know but
maybe in case um some of the listeners
um don't is the MDMA causes these
massive increases in serotonin that
seems to be the major source of the MDMA
effect so to speak um based on the work
of our colleague Rob malanka and um in
at least one human study comparing um
MDMA to very high does oxytocin
treatment ruled out the oxytocin Spike
that's induced by MDMA as the as the
source or the only source but of course
these chemicals can synergize I mean but
based on its chemical profile oxytocin
release massive serotonin release
dopamine release and a propensity to
enhance neuroplasticity I mean assuming
all the safety protocols were were there
um seems like not the perfect drug but
not a bad choice um if of course it's
inducing the kind of plasticity that
someone with autism would be seeking
right I mean I think I think the tricky
part especially in children right is
there's going to be a reluctance to
potentially give them psychedelics right
and so you know is there a way to
modify um you know the chemical compound
to you know be something that parents
might be more willing to give to their
children right right and I totally agree
with that um I guess to play Devil's
Advocate not against you but um uh well
I'll just state it very directly and
then I I'll take the heat as necessary
um I mean I've done two episodes about
the uh the drugs that you know Millions
tens of millions if not hundreds of
millions of parents are already giving
their kids for ADHD which are um include
amphetamines including dioxine
methamphetamine is actually a
prescription drug for a very small
subset of kids with ADHD but things like
adderal viance even methylphenidate rlin
I mean these are amphetamines they
induce dopamine release and
norepinephrine release and uh again I'm
not suggesting people um give their kids
MDMA um to try and amarate symptoms of
autism but something chemically similar
to it ought to be developed or at least
explored in a human trial in my in my
opinion well time will tell I'll reach
out to the maps group and see see what's
happening let's talk about vasopress yes
because there's a lot to discuss there
so you told us this is a molecule that
chemically is very similar to oxytocin
um is it manufactured in the human brain
and body yes okay do we know a subset of
the sites that it's known to be produced
and where it's of its actions are and
you mentioned the kidney and the
anti-diuretic hormone um roles but
within the brain like what brain areas
have neurons that make vasopressin well
or have the receptors for I mean The
receptors are all over are all over the
brain and again it varies depending on
the species and you know the way the
receptors are measured or in postmortem
tissue right which can be very difficult
to get good samples right and so we need
to have that caveat going in um but yeah
I mean it's it's made in the
hypothalamus um and it's released all
over the brain and there is vasor press
and receptors all over the brain right
and um what's really interesting about
vaser press and I always sort of joke
that oxytocin you know always saw its
day in the sun if you will and the
vasopress was sort of the stepchild that
was like left you know sort of behind
and and the reason why I find this
fascinating is again like I think back
to my you know my my roots as a you know
evolutionary biologist behavioral
neuroscientist and what was interesting
is that there were studies in the early
to mid 1990 showing that vasopressin was
critical for male social behavior and so
um there was work you know there was a
variety of people and I I think Rob
Minka mentioned this on his on on the
podcast he did about you know there's a
a group of people like Sue Carter Larry
young Tom inso some of these early
people and they gave Vasa pressen to
male Prairie voles and V
vasopressin was what induced um pair
bonding um with a a female mate and also
paternal care and and as I recall those
experiments were done in the context of
looking at um polygamy versus monogamy
of these Prairie VES um Prairie VES
versus like a different species so same
um genus but a different species so it
might be a Montaine V or you know highly
related but these other species so
Perales are monogamous the males uh well
I mean that was the 50% divorce right
yeah that was I don't think it's that
bad but I think they're doing better
than we are as a species that's true we
should look to them for pointers and all
the divorce folks are saying wait why'
you say better I have some divorce
friends that have said divorce is like
the greatest thing so we always say like
doing better doing worse right um anyway
that's a whole other podcast um and
certainly not the hubman Lab podcast but
or maybe it is but um or will be but
yeah my understanding is is that you
have certain vs that mate with almost
exclusively with one other V for their
entire lifespan and then you have other
vs located elsewhere um that in those
colonies they mate with lots of
different well so the males and females
have lots of different partners um rais
young with lots of different partners
mating with lots of different partners
and that if you give Vasa presson then
you can make the I was want to call them
polyamorous but I don't know if they
love each other I'm going to answer for
more and assume they love each other the
polygamous moles not polyamorous but
polygamous moles then become monogamous
well I yeah I would say that is probably
not the take-home message so the
take-home message would be they had
let's say that there was like the good
vs right which are the Prairie VES and
they were the ones that formed these
monogamous parir bonds dad participates
in paternal care with Mom they co- ra
babies together and then Dad chases off
Intruders right and then there's the
more Ace social vs and so these are like
the Montaine VES um and um we'll we'll
see it's a complicated story but there's
these Montaine vs where um males and
females live separately females like
maybe live on the male's territory the
male mes with a few different females
absolutely doesn't provide any paternal
care at all mom raises babies by herself
right so that's these are really the
like 1950s versus 2020s yes yes to be to
to broadly stereotype to broadly
stereotype and if you give okay so for
Prairie voles they're sort of primed to
form bonds and to be the males to be
good daddies if you will and all you
have to do is give them a single
injection of vasopressin and you know or
you can give an antagonist and usually
the way they form the bond is through
mating right so they you put them with a
female they mate they cohabit for a bit
there's been all kinds of parametric
studies I I can't remember how many
hours it takes to form a parabond um but
then you can do these things called
partner preference tests and then you
can say here's the guy that you made it
with here's this guy you don't know and
you can do it for males you can do it
for females and they pick their partner
they choose to go hang out with their
partner the Montaine BS you know either
after meting with somebody May either be
equal or maybe they'll even go spend
time with the new individual so the
cleanest story was that Prairie voles
are monogamous Mont voles are not
monogamous but in the prairie vs you
could give vasor pressen instead of
mated cohabitation and you could turn on
a like you know a bond with somebody
after only living with them for a very
short period of time right um or you
could induce paternal behavior and I was
working with a V species in grad school
I think the most interesting scientific
experience that I've ever had right and
you and I both know this right when
you're young you're actually the person
doing the work right as you become you
know the head of your lab you're mostly
writing grants and giving talks right
and then you get to hear about the super
cool things that every in your lab is
doing right eventually the the members
of your laboratory kick you out of the
lab they literally say like get out of
here you're leaving things in the wrong
place whereas initially you're telling
them hey that's in the wrong place
within a year or two for me I think it
took about four or five years but by
about year six right I was um demoted to
my office to just write grants and write
Pap I was told that one time I was back
there and I tried to waigh and I was
like so excited what they were working
on and they basically just said go write
grants and bring in more money right
like that was kind of their attitude
like we get to be the ones who get to do
the cool stuff so back when I got to
actually do the science um I remember I
had this species where and I and again I
told you I came at this from an
evolutionary perspective so these were
called meadowes and I found them very
interesting so when I showed up in my
thesis advisor lab she I said I really
want to study oxytocin and vasopressin
and I really want to study VES and I
know you have a v species and she said
why I don't have prairie vs I have these
meow voles and I'm studying them because
they're so sensitive to light and they
changed their behavior based on light
and I she said well you can do what you
want but our grants basically have to
have a circadian component and so she
said you got to work that in but then we
kind of struck this deal so I was
hanging out in the animal rooms and I
thought it was really fascinating so she
had animals that were either on short
day lengths or long day lengths so the
mimicking some um summer and winter and
I was noticing that on winter day
lengths the the males were hanging out
with the females and when the female had
a litter he was like participating and I
was like whoa these are not supposed to
be monogamous animals and so I went into
the field research and they were doing
all these radio telemetry studies and so
like if you I we should probably explain
what those are putting a little
transmitter um under the skin it's
painless for the animal but that allows
the researcher to um monitor the
behavior of the animal remotely without
having to you know put them in cages and
stuff so and so this is like under field
conditions and vs are everybody's
favorite snack so they have like a very
limited lifespan in the wild I mean like
on the order of months and and so like
if you have a short lifespan like you
should just keep reproducing right and
so what was interesting is at the end of
the summer days as you're going into
winter territories collapse and males
are found with females and they co- ra
babies it makes sense if it's you're
going to have a litter and mom needs to
get up to go eat you need somebody to
sit there and warm those babies or
they're going to die because they're
going to freeze to death right so I
started saying like wow I think these
metales are good dats like I'm noticing
this and so I told my thesis adviser I
want to study how oxytocin invasor press
can maybe this is involved in tracking
these evolutionary mating strategies and
so again like the coolest experience I
ever had was on these males that were
housed under short day length so they
were like winter males um I was able to
put Vaso pressent directly into their
brains and and it was like turning on a
light switch and they ran around the
cage picked up all these babies put them
in a nest and huddled over them and if
you put a placebo into their brain
nothing happened and so to me I always
filed that away in you know in the back
of my mind of like wow Vasa pressin is
this really interesting hormone um and
maybe someday I will I did a postto on
something else but it was always you
know back in the back of my mind of I
really want to return to this it's so
incredible that a eight amino acid long
peptide could basically turn these um
relatively negligent fathers into very
attentive fathers yes yeah it was
fascinating right that I mean it just
speaks to the power of the peptide baso
pressent also speaks to the power of
brain circuitry it also speaks to the
idea that brain circuitry is often
sitting latent in the background you
know ready to be activated that it's not
just about neuroplasticity and building
up a new circuit that some forms of
neuroplasticity are about unveiling
what's what's already there and that
peptides can act like switches um which
you know kind of makes sense on the one
hand but um I've never heard of a result
as dramatic as that so
um I'm presuming you're going to tell us
that that then LED you to go back to
vasopress and explore its ability to
induce good parenting and negligent
fathers I haven't studied that yet um no
well so I think that you know my mom
always says Chance favors the prepared
mind and so I was doing my postto at
Stanford and I got recruited to stay on
the faculty and I you know had been
doing work in stress vulnerability and
stress resilience and I really and I
love doing that work but I still felt
this tug of you know I had spent all
this time in a Psychiatry department
where I was surrounded by clinicians and
I realized that a lot of the stuff that
I was doing had clinical relevance right
and so sometimes you sort of meet the
moment right and so right as I was
transitioning to to have my own lab in
my department there was uh a bunch of
stuff going on so there were a lot of
very dedicated parents who were lobbying
for funding for autism research because
it was horrifically underfunded really
horrifically underfunded wow I mean at
rates of one in 36 well not at the time
right so it was it was 1 in 150 or
whatever it was back then but there were
all these parents and and I I mean again
they're heroes in my eyes that they ad
ated so much for their loved ones and so
there was you know they started forming
parent Grassroots organizations that
have culminated they all started joining
together which is now Autism Speaks um
and then there was a man named Jim
Simons who runs um one of the most
successful hedge funds in the world and
he decided wow I'm gonna you know
there's let's put money into autism
right and so does he have a personal
link to autism I you'd have to ask him
because often times not always but often
times when you hear about um wealthy
donors um devoting a lot of money to one
area of science there's there's a
familial thing there you know a member
of their family or a close friend has
this Challenge and they they really want
to see that challenge absolutely I mean
a lot of money I've gotten for my lab
from philanthropist and what I will say
is the most impactful work I've ever
done is through philanthropy right there
are crazy ideas that no funding agency
ever touches right um but yeah so they
put they both put um a lot you know
there there was a lot of emphasis and so
because the s's Foundation started
issuing requests for applications there
was a group at Stanford that formed and
it was um um a clinician with a basic
scientist and my chair at the time said
well you know almost nothing is known
about the biological basis of autism why
don't you go I'm going to introduce you
to the the the head of child psychiatry
you should go talk to this group and so
as I Was preparing my slides and
realizing that you know social
interaction impairments were a core
feature of autism I thought wow you know
these neuropeptides May really be you
know um a part of this puzzle and so
that's actually really how I got pulled
into um autism research was was through
that and it was I I was you know
everybody at the time was very
interested in oxytocin and you know I
remember thinking so we actually did
probably the most definitive blood
oxytocin um study because there was this
idea again like this marketing campaign
of like the oxytocin deficit hypothesis
of autism and you know given how
clinically heterogeneous autism was we
got money actually from the Simons
foundation and we did the first study
with maybe 200 kids um and what we were
able to show was that blood oxytocin was
not a marker of autism right so it
wasn't like there was a bimodal
distribution meaning two completely
nonoverlapping levels of oxytocin in
people with Autism people without autism
so the lower your blood oxytocin levels
um actually regardless of who you were
you could be a child with autism you
could be an unaffected sibling with
autism or you could be a unrelated
control child and it was the lower your
blood oxytocin levels the greater your
sort of social difficulties and the
slopes you know were different they
started at different points because the
behaviors were obviously different but
that's what got us thinking about our
clinical trial which is that blood
oxytocin level is not going to be this
great differentiator between people with
and without autism right but we might be
able to find a subgroup who could
benefit from treatment but what I like
so much about your approach the way you
described it is that it it sets aside we
don't we don't want to say discards but
it sets aside this thing that we call
autism yeah which is already hard to
Define and diagnose and there's all
these different spectrums and you're
trying to F and just says okay children
with autism have challenges in social
cognition social behavior social bonding
yeah so do adults with autism for that
matter matter let's just focus on that
yeah and not worry so much about whether
or not somebody is diagnosed as Autistic
or not and just focus on what are some
of the potential neuropeptide deficits
or overexpression of neuropeptides that
may in some way relate to those Social
Challenges right and then one can Circle
back to the question about autism in
collecting those data but it also points
to this idea that like when we when we
go after a disease like Alzheimer we can
often miss the possibility that
Alzheimer's while it has you know
deficits in cognition and memory could
also be a bunch of other things like a
metabolic disorder of the body and so
maybe you go after a particular
symptomology yeah and try and attack
that and you might actually potentially
treat or cure multiple diseases it's a
very different approach and I I hope um
people are catching on to the the
subtlety but also the the the potential
impact of that um because if I heard
correctly you said there are people who
are not autistic who have social
functioning deficits and they too have
less circulating oxytocin right so I
would say we haven't studied people
where we brought them in and
characterized it right so these are
typically developing kids but what we
did is in the abilities that are typical
of a controlled child we still saw that
gradient right and so I think it just
sort of begs the question about you know
what is oxytocin's role in human
sociality right I mean I think there's
just so much that we don't understand
about both of these molecules um in
terms of their disease liability if
they're low or their healing potential
if we are you know able to use them as
modulators um of other
therapies so how did you move from
oxytocin to vasopressin um you mentioned
that everyone was was all excited about
oxytocin still the one that we hear the
most about yeah although after this
podcast episode and when I start
blabbing about vas oppress to everybody
um you know maybe that'll change but
it's I think it's going to take a lot
more than that but um maybe it's because
the name isn't as there's something
about oxytocin that like kind of sounds
like the love looks like the love
hormone but like vasopressin should be
renamed right well it should be called
something else like not anti-erotic
hormone not vasopressin I mean you're
going to tell us how critically
important it is perhaps even more
important than oxytocin for autism and
social functioning so I don't know by
the end of this podcast we'll we'll come
up with a new name I it's needed right
well I'll put it out there um uh okay so
how did you get to vas oppressor okay so
it was interesting with oxytocin because
we didn't you know and again I was
skeptical that we would see these big
group differences but you know it was a
little bit of like okay you know what
everyone's saying this is not going to
be the big solution right um and so I
actually came at it from the work that
we did in monkeys and so I think I
mentioned previously at the beginning of
the podcast that there were a lot of
limitations that I saw and then
sometimes if you come into a field you
know when you're you're a little bit of
an outsider right like I'm not a
clinician I don't see autism patients
but I also I have this really strong
interest in social behavior and the
biology of it and so I I was thinking
about what are what are things that we
need to do to better address the
challenges in autism so one of them was
why are we looking in blood right like
if you look at neurological conditions
there's been a lot of progress made by
doing biomarker Discovery in cerebral
spinal fluid right so like the the
biological substrates or or clues of
markers of say um various forms of
Dementia or um or MS were for first
found in spinal fluid right because it's
the it's the fluid that bathes the brain
in the spinal column and so if you're
looking for the bio chemistry of an
illness that's the closest fluid that
you can get to the brain right so blood
draw just won't do it maybe right so
that was part of my thinking but then
there was the issue of the animal models
right so there was drug after drug after
drug that was tested in mice and they
failed in human clinical trials and so
it made me start thinking could we
develop a primate model um of naturally
occurring social impairments right so
can we because in autism these social
impairments are if you will naturally
occurring right and so you know this is
these spontaneously occur in children um
and so it made me wonder could we
identify monkeys in a large Colony that
have social
impairments in and after talking to to
clinicians who who treat these children
can I spend a lot of time validating a
monkey model where there will be monkeys
that have features that look like they
have direct relevance to core autism
symptoms um and so what I did was
there's a um primate Center the
California National Primate Research
Center and so what we did is so I think
I mentioned earlier that there's these
surveys that can be used to look at
autistic traits in the general human
population right and so we refined one
of these and we did what we call back
translate so basically it's an
instrument that's used for humans and
then what we did is modified it to be
able to to use this rating scale in
reesus Max which are an old world monkey
and I know you're familiar with them and
um and I was interested in looking at
Old World monkeys because they're some
of the closest relatives to human that
are used in biomedical research and and
um as I mentioned previously these
autistic traits are continuously
distributed across the general human
population and that this
genetic uh say let's call it genetic
liability which is a fancy way of just
saying that we think that there's a
there's a genetic risk that underlies
this Continuum of Behavioral traits
right so if we think that that's true in
humans and in one of our closest
relatives and we think that some of
these genes create proteins that then
are what sets up the developing brain to
develop in the way that autistic brains
develop so let's just assume that that's
the premise that's what we went with can
we find reesus maacs that are just
living in large outdoor colonies and
identify animals that might be good um
models for autism and the answer is yes
we could do this all kinds of different
ways one is we could just take people
and um score monkey behaviors outside
their cages while they're interacting
with their peers we can use rating
scales and again the rating scale we Ed
it's called the social responsiveness
scale so this is called the MAAC social
responsiveness scale revised it's a
mouthful um but what it allows us to do
is measure autistic like traits in
monkeys and we can also bring monkeys in
for experimental test to see where their
eyes look or how do they perform how do
they respond to videos of other monkeys
you know if they're making affiliate of
overtures do they um do like you know
you know ma goo which is a a positive
response well they do that right I I um
I'm going to apologize for interrupting
you again but I just have to tell people
this because I spent time up at the UC
Davis primate Center as a graduate
student and and by the way what we're
referring to here are non-invasive
observational studies at least thus far
so these are monkeys living in large uh
exclosures not enclosures large
exclosures um forming colonies and
social relationships and um you know I
think anyone that sees monkeys at the
zoo and we all learn that monkeys go and
they don't if you want a monkey to like
you you learn this working with macx um
first of all they don't the affiliative
call is
a they do this really nice and the
little ones the babies I spend a lot of
time with these monkeys and the little
ones they do this thing where they go I
used to I used to nurse the little ones
every once in a while they and they're
just you know just like makes your heart
melt I think there must have been an
oxytocin dump at that moment that's
probably happening right now but if you
want the monkeys to like you you have to
give an affiliative facial gesture which
is not a smile that's actually an
aggressive gesture so as Karen Dr Parker
just showed you it's lip smacking which
is so if you see a monkey at the zoo and
you want it to pay attention to you
you're going to have to lip smack and if
it doesn't either you're not doing it
right or it just doesn't like you
exactly right great all right thanks now
we'll go back to the uh the study of uh
or the establishment of this really key
experiment right so then what we did is
we identified these these animals and we
spent a lot of time so one one of the
things that I do as one of my areas of
expertise is validating animal model so
a lot of like I mentioned like a lot of
reason why experiments fail is people
will take an animal off the shelf and
say oh I'm going to do this right but if
you're you know if you're studying a
disorder that's characterized by visual
issues is it is it the best thing to do
in a nocturnal species that has old
faction as its primary sensory modality
or you're referring to mice right or is
it better you know and again I will say
all models have value there's all you
know there's reasons you just have to
you know you basically have to stand by
what you're modeling and so I think one
of my the biggest issues I have with a
sort of mouse phenotyping Mafia is that
you know there's this group of tests
that they use and they use it in every
single disorder right and then if
there's a positive hit it's like oh this
is like you know this test is really for
Parkinson's today but it's for
depression tomorrow right and so so my
goal was to to devise very specific
tests that would allow us to evaluate
you know core features of autism in this
model and the answer is we found it
right so if you you look at monkeys that
spend a lot of time alone they have a
much greater burden of autistic like
traits measuring on this rating scale
they have diminished social motivations
so other monkeys will come up and
interact with them but they don't engage
in um social overtures them that much
themselves they do less grooming less uh
affiliative um behaviors um they in some
of the work that we're doing they don't
lip smack back and we can talk a little
bit about that we did a pharmacological
probe and we can talk a bit about what
vasor press does to that which is kind
of exciting um and so we spent a lot of
time validating this behavioral
phenotype right to say that we really
feel like there are are core aspects of
it that are allowing us to model autism
right um and I have a paper which if you
want to put it in it's all about
creating this monkey model and and and
the power of of doing it and where it it
took us clinically we will provide a
link to that in the show note captions I
also just want to um throw up my vote
for the the fact that you did this work
because again I I don't disparage Mouse
model work but we've just seen over and
over again that the incredibly small
fraction of mouse models that lead to uh
valid Therapeutics in humans and that
there's just a lot of differences
between um primate brains and rodent
brains and we have a very elaborate you
know frontal cortex a bunch of other
circuitry that might if they have the
that they probably use it for other
things and it's just very hard to com to
draw conclusions from those models and
and they're they're great for probing um
functions that are uh let's just call
them more autonomic type functions um
and for doing some of the initial
investigations but um you know I think
while I don't want to see every research
lab switch over to primates you know I
think one has to be really thoughtful
about the kinds of experiments one does
with primates at all yeah um this sort
of um behavioral assessment and and the
identification of a of a primate model
for autism seems like a a very good use
of of um of Human Resources right well
and the other thing I will say is that
there were medications that were only
tested in rodents that when they were
when they were tested in people had
really negative consequences I can give
you two examples so one is the lamide
which was a morning sickness medication
that was given to women um that were
pregnant um and the safety testing and
talks was toxicity testing was done only
in mice I didn't know that yes and
that's why it went on the market it went
on the market in Europe um and there
were all these children born with
profound lib limb abnormalities when
they went back and tested the drug in um
marma sets neither rees's monkeys or
cinus monkeys an old world monkey they
had the limb abnormalities and so all
they had to do and again you know I I as
an animal lover treat the you know the
life of a single monkey or or a single
Mouse for that matter an individual
monkey excuse me or individual Mouse for
that matter as you know as critical I am
a species I do think there's a
difference between their life and our
lives when it comes to um you know what
study one does but um but just the idea
that these severe developmental defects
in humans could have been avoided by
doing an experiment perhaps even on one
right maret right um and again I feel
for the life of discomfort of that maret
but um the idea that that could have
saved so many human lives it's just
striking well and there was also that
street drug MP TP that was a synthetic
heroin right that caused like overnight
parkinsonian ISM right when like I think
the dopamine cells were just oblad right
but when you went and looked in mice
mptp didn't have those effects it was
only in primates and other or humans and
other primates right so and I agree with
you I am an animal lover I I think that
we have to be very careful whenever we
do any animal experiments right and so
you really need to have a good
justification I think for any science
that's done I will say that upfront um
and you know we have this you know new
generation of stem cell and organoid
work which I think is going to you know
allow us to make all kinds of disease
progress right so without having to
study uh whole animal models or in in
complimentary right but I mean I think
again I think we need to pick the model
based on the question we're asking right
and so if you want to have a medication
that's safe and well tolerated you know
in people um were effective and you want
to move the needle on Lex social
cognition you want to be testing it in a
species that also has complex social
cognition look the Netflix show chimp
Empire people haven't seen it they
should watch it when you watch it you
realize they're very much like us yeah
and dare I say we're very much like them
oh yeah it's uh Far and Away different
than watching a bunch of mice yes and
I'm not being disparaging of mice I'm
assuming they have that mice also have
complex social cognition VES also have
complex social cognition but it's of the
mouse V type and we don't know really
even what to look for right but with
primates there's you know affiliative
gaze there's you know affiliative
grooming there's um ostracization of
individuals in a troop I mean there's a
there's a you know baning taking care of
other babies there's all sorts of
interesting dynamics that map so clearly
onto human behavior and vice versa yeah
yeah so you establish this Colony up at
Davis um at the regional primate Center
that and where you identified some
monkeys that we don't if they have
autism but you could see that they were
less socially affiliative right and I
would never say they have autism like I
will say that up front you know they
have features that resemble human autism
and that allow us to model this right so
so we started studying those animals and
what we wanted to do was do some
biomarker Discovery so what we wanted to
ask was are there any molecules that
allow us to differentiate these what
we'll call them naturally low social or
low social monkeys from soci socially
competent high social monkeys and so we
measured a bunch of different um
readouts of neurotransmitter systems
that were either involved in Maman
social behavior had been implicated in
idiopathic meaning autism that doesn't
have a genetic cause or these
neurogenetic syndromes that we've been
talking about um where there's Pathways
that are really associated with them and
so if we measured a bunch of these
systems with 93% accuracy without even
knowing what the monkey who the monkey
was if they were low or high social we
could just put them in the low social or
high social bucket and was this by blood
draw or cerebral spinal this was it was
everything we did Blood we did CSF and
we put all these measures into the
hopper we did a discriminate statistical
analysis which was like a machine
learning algorithm where we just said
here's all this information help me
classify if this individual is high or
low social for cerebral spinal fluid is
collected by spinal tap correct in my
understanding I've never had one um but
that spinal tap is of course more
invasive than a blood draw but it still
is um done as an outpatient thing in
humans like you can go in get a needle
inserted into the lower spine by by an
expert um they're going to draw cerebral
spinal fluid I mean not that much more
invasive and timec consuming than
getting a a needle into your vein for a
blood draw right I mean it's it's we
think of it as it's technically a little
bit more challenging um but their CSF
draw humans all the time right so in
theory this could map to a human study
and it did which we'll talk about cool
so we went out and we did this I have
this spectacular statistician who's we
we spend a lot of time together his name
is Joe Garner and um and he is a
statistical genius and so he developed
this and and we do all of our work
together or you know I would say 95% of
it we just love working together and he
developed a statistical winning winwing
strategy to identify what were the key
drivers and what was fascinating is in
this first monkey cohort it was the
cerebral spinal fluid levels of
vasopressin that were really what was
driving this classification right so if
we just knew your levels of your of
vasor pressent in spinal fluid but not
in blood interestingly um we could
pretty closely perfect to perfect
classify you as high or low social and
so then we replicated that again in
another monkey cohort because obviously
it's a scientists you always want to
replicate your work and then if it was
really a biomarker meaning it's a
molecule in the body that gives us um an
indication of something and in this case
it's an indication of your Social
functioning we were able to look at um
monkeys and we saw that the Vasa
pressent was consistent across
measurement time so there was a wide
variety of Vasa pressin levels but
within an individual monkey it was
pretty much the same right so that's
what you want to see with the biomarker
and then we showed that the vasor
pressen levels were closely uh linked to
uh groom SP grooming uh time spending
grooming and as we mentioned I think we
mentioned earlier grooming is in many
monkey species a critical behavior that
solidifies social bonds and maintains
them and so the individuals with the
lowest CSF phasor pressent levels had uh
spent the less time the least amount of
time in in grooming grooming other
monkeys other monkeys yeah this
allopathic grooming is a very
interesting behavior and um from
watching chimp Empire I can tell you
that um new relationships are
established in many ways by um monkeys
these chimps chimpanzees sort of
offering their back for grooming and if
another um chimp elects to yes groom
that um chimp then it establishes some
form of trust and it and it all seems to
have to do with proximity like how close
are you going to let me get to you vice
versa in humans that you know we talk
about personal space and there's a whole
set of things related to consent in this
whole allopathic grooming thing and then
if they um you know if a if a chimp
misbehaves on on an outing then they
aren't groomed by others and they can
actually get parasitic infections and it
can be very costly uh it's very
interesting you know uh to just think of
alpath grooming as a as not a um kind of
a primitive of language but a whole
language into itself absolutely yeah and
and also just critical for the species
so that was really interesting to me
that we were seeing these hints that
vasor pressin could be you know really
important but of course you know
somebody will say and I will say upfront
monkeys don't have autism right so then
the question becomes does this have
what's called translational value so you
know can I see this observation in an an
animal model and will it provide
fundamental insights into humans right
and so I wanted to get cerebral spinal
fluid from people um to test this
hypothesis because we had in parallel
done a study looking at blood vas
oppress levels and people within without
autism and we didn't see a group
difference there unlike this really
profound difference that we saw when we
looked at spinal fluid and the monkey
and again I think I mentioned the blood
vasor press levels were
indistinguishable if you were higher low
social monkeys so there was something
about looking more proximate to the
brain that was giving us more
information than say the blood alone and
so I said I wanted to get spinal fluid
and like you said people do this all the
time how would we um but we're you know
it's not going to be a first pass
especially when we don't really have any
evidence in people to go in for what we
would call a research lumbar puncture
right and so I had to get really
creative about how do I get spinal fluid
from children and what we did was we
piggybacked on to a clinical indication
for um a spinal fluid draw so and and we
did this so I tried to get funding for
this this is like you know again I mean
I think this is important for people to
know how science is done right and so I
wrote all these Grant applications
nobody would fund it they said that this
is really interesting it's too high risk
you won't be able to pull it off and you
know I don't usually back down from a
challenge like if I think think
something's a good idea and I want to do
it I'm going to find a way to do it if
somebody if it's impossible that's one
thing but if it's hard to do it doesn't
mean you shouldn't do it you just have
to figure out how to do it and so I
always try to see Bridges where other
people see barriers right and so it's
like well how can I access spinal fluid
and so I went around talking to all my
friends who were on and Stanford's
really wonderful because it's such a
small school right and so you're on all
these different committees with all
these different people and so lot of
committees lots of I can attest lot of
Comm exactly but it's really because
you're on them with people from all
different departments I know people in
departments that I wouldn't otherwise
know um and you get very uh you get to
know these people well in these many
committees and where we live it's a
small community right so like maybe were
the experiment Karen maybe there's a I
always wonder whether or not there's a
larger experiment right not on monkeys
not on the the patients or the Clone but
like we're maybe we're the experiment
right and they're looking at how we
interact on committees anyway please
continue so I started going up to people
that I knew and said hey if you're
you're taking spinal fluid can I get a
little bit of extra right and of course
we got you know IRB approval meaning we
had ethics approval and all this and um
or you could get the remnant sample and
obviously again get consent from the
families so we could either get a little
bit extra when it was being drawn for a
research indication so so they were
getting a spinal tap no matter what and
then we were just either we're getting a
little bit extra or we were going to
getting the remnant that they were going
to throw out right so you usually take
more than you need because you don't
want to have to do another spinal tap
right and so we were able to go around
and I hustled around and got all these
people involved to help me we put um hot
pink stickers on the lumbar puncture
trays so that in the emergency room so
if somebody was doing a spinal tap they
would call us so we knew about it and we
could get you know samples um again
under people's consent um so we got all
these people involved and we finally got
samples from children with autism and
children without autism and then we also
made sure that whatever they were being
worked up for was negative right so we
got the the sort of healthiest people we
could given that everybody was coming in
for a medical reason to have a lumbar
puncture and in this in this first study
we had seven children with autism seven
children without autism and we could
nearly perfectly classify 13 out of 14
individuals by just knowing their CSF
vasor pressent level Alone um which is
pretty remarkable given that there isn't
a biological indicator that we a robust
biological IND Ator that we know so
basically in this relatively small
cohort yeah having low vasopress is the
biomarker of autism correct and and
again and what I will say is in our
monkey studies and in our human studies
CSF oxytocin level became our control
right so in our monkeys there were no
difference in CSF oxytocin by group um
and then in this first study um there
were no differences in CSF oxytocin
levels um uh a sample size of 14 is
intriguing but given autism so
clinically heterogeneous we want to
replicate it and so I knew that there
was um a professor at the NIH named um
Sue swedo who was collecting uh cerebral
spinal fluid in as part of a research
study because she was interested in
immune parameters and fate deficiency so
she had children that were medically
healthy and they were getting you know
just like at ni you get these huge
workups right so they were very
well-characterized participants so we
were able to look at and again we also
this is the first time we were able to
look at girls so we had a small sample
of girls and we had boys and we
basically just asked the question can we
replicate this and I was very interested
in well will oxytocin be what's
different in the girls right so maybe
there will be some sex specificity here
and that we'll see low CSF vasor pressin
in the males and low CSF oxytocin girls
that was not the case what we found was
that if in the individuals with autism
regardless of their um biological sex um
that they all had lower CSF phasor
presson levels than the individuals
without autism and because they were so
well characterized we were also able to
show on a gold standard research
diagnostic assessment of autism so it's
a an assessment that's used um uh to in
a research situation to validate an
Autism diagnosis by an expert clinical
opinion that the lower your vasopress
levels in spinal fluid the greater your
um social symptom severity um your
clinical symptom severity and then we
asked it's like well vasor press's
involved in social behavior but it's not
really that involved in restricted
repetitive behaviors and that was
actually the case so it was the CSF Vasa
press and track the social symptom
severity not the repetitive symptom
severity suggesting that there might be
other biological measures that could be
included as a way to you know have a
more powerful way to differentiate
people with and without autism um and so
then I was really so so that was really
exciting to replicate that um and then I
had a colleague named um John
Constantino who um is now at Emery but
he used to be at wasio and I knew that
John I had been at a meeting in I think
it was 2010 and I found out that he had
what I will call Liquid Gold so he had
this uh minus 80 uh C freezer um that
was uh had a bunch of um neonatal infant
CSF samples that he had from Human
infants and he had collected them and
again this was under ethical approvals
and it was basically they these infants
came in for something that needed to be
worked up that was very rare um but if
they had it they would you know they
they could die so they needed to get a
medical treatment for it but the the
vast majority of these children ended up
being healthy so it was a pretty healthy
sample if you will right and so I knew
he had all these samples and I said to
him wouldn't it be really interesting if
we teamed up and we look at this uh CSF
vaser press finding in children before
the period when behavioral symptoms
first manifest right and so so sorry
again to I'm going to apologize every
time no no no I just but I think it's
important because this was a question
that um I was thinking about earlier and
I imagine many other people were too you
know you find these monkeys that have
social uh interaction deficits you find
um kids that have social interaction
deficits and you see that there's low
vasopress in both groups this extends to
male and female children but then of
course the question becomes well maybe
they have low vas oppress because of so
many years or even months of social
interaction deficits right that the the
direction of causality isn't clear and
so yeah when you said Liquid Gold you
know referring to the um CSF from these
infants um taken prior to any
opportunity for social interaction
Beyond just you know whatever
interaction they had with their their
mother up until the point the the CSF
draw was taken um this really gets at
the issue of causality right so it's a
quasi perspective you know because it
was banked and then a lot of time went
by right and so what we realized we
could do was and this was a heroic
undertaking on John's part so these were
um this was these samples were collected
back on paper medical records so he had
to trace 2,000 paper paper what's that
yeah exactly so he had to trace 2,000 I
think paper medical records to an
electronic medical record and then what
we did is we he looked to see who went
on to develop autism and who didn't
right so then what we had with spinal
fluid samples that have sort of been
waiting in the freezer if you will and
then we could ask you know do
individuals who later receive an Autism
diagnosis many months or even years
later already have low vasopress levels
as infants and the reason why this was a
compelling question to ask is there's
evidence to suggest that behavioral
therapies are more effective the younger
the child is right and if you think
about it if if behavioral
characteristics of autism emerge across
development you know what if and this
was my this is sort of my we haven't we
haven't substantiated this yet but this
is like sort of my big question what if
all these autism susceptibility genes
summon interact and converge upon a few
common Pathways in the brain right and
so for years people have talked about
this excitatory inhibitory balance
theory of autism but what if vas oppress
is one of those Pathways because it's so
critically involved in Social
functioning and so what I was interested
in and so let let's just say for a
moment you know your genes are set at
Birth what if the Vaso prestent is
already low in the brains of these
infants and so it puts them on this very
different trajectory where you have this
cumulative effect of they're maybe a
little bit less socially interested and
maybe they're not making the eye contact
and if there was a way to intervene
really early even potentially with a
vasopress and replacement therapy that
you might be able to put them on a
different developmental trajectory so
that was my big what if question
and what was really remarkable was so I
had been asking John hey can I have your
spinal fluid samples and and he finally
agreed after he saw a couple of those
papers understandably he wanted to make
sure that we already had shown something
in people and animals that were sort of
if you will symptomatic with social
impairment and what we found was yes
this was the case so it was a small
sample it needs to be replicated but
individual so infants that went on to
have an Autism diagnosis later in life
already had low CSF vasor pressent level
oxytocin levels did not differ between
infants that received a subsequent
autism diagnosis and those that didn't
so suggesting that we have a
biomarker that you know might really be
a good readout for you know clinical
referral or risk management monitoring
incredible so you're telling us that
levels of
vasopressin correlate with social
cognition deficits that right I think
that warrants a brief discussion about
cerebral spinal fluid I teach neuro
Anatomy to medical students so um
forgive me for for having to ask this
but you know I think of cerebral spinal
fluid as the stuff that exists in the
ventricles and down the central Canal
the spinal cord and provides essential
nutrients and uh for neurons and other
cell types in the
brain but it's also a reservoir for
chemicals coming from the brain which is
why the spinal tap is useful right um
but
in the context of a cerebral spinal tap
and you're measuring CSF and you're
seeing okay lower levels of vas oppress
in these individuals with these
challenges with social deficits does
that mean that they're making less
vasopressin does it mean I mean it could
have gone the other way too like they're
dumping too much vasopressin into the
CSF and it's not able to function in the
brain
like you know what do we know about CSF
and what does it mean right well I mean
it's a great question so I I think this
is just the tip of the iceberg right so
I think of the CSF as as sort of like
the kitchen sink of the brain right and
what we need is real specificity and so
I mean my working hypothesis and we'll
talk a little bit about pharmacology is
that there's a deficiency in um in vasor
produ vasor pressent production in
individuals with autism but there's a
lot of elegant experiments that need to
be done to be able to answer this
question so we have funding ly to look
in um postmortem human brain tissue um
to look at um in both blood CSF and
hypothalamic tissue where vasopress is
made to look at inner relationships
right which is very difficult to do but
also to see if there's a fewer number of
Vaso pressent producing cells and if
Vaso pressent gene expression is
diminished right because that would help
us begin to answer is this a production
issue right so if you think back to the
Prairie V
they're sort of primed to be parental
right um or in in my case the mees right
but you can do this in any V species
well at least the two that I'm thinking
of and you put baso pressent into the
brain and then all of a sudden it it
unlocks this Behavior right so is it
possible that children with autism or at
least a subset of them um all you have
to do is replace vasopress and that
there might be a subset of these kids
minimally that could benefit from vasor
presson replacement if you will
is there any evidence for excessive
urination in kids with autism which if
anyone's going what what why is he
asking that if you recall vas supressant
is also anti-diuretic hormone um I
suppose the other question is could you
has anyone looked at levels of a oppress
in the urine of autistic kids versus
non-autistic kids because it's acting
peripherally and um you said blood draws
don't reveal any differences um in
circulating blood we know that you're
urine is filtered blood fair enough but
um seems at least worth worth a looky
okay so I have this awesome medical
student in my lab named Lauren Clark and
we with um three different Physicians
from different backgrounds so um wrote a
perspective piece that's currently under
review and it actually asked this
question so you know given all these
weird medical naming conventions it's
possible that this information is
existing in information silos in
different disciplines right so it raises
this idea of if you have low vasopressin
so there's a if you really don't have
you're not making vasopress you have a
disorder called Central diabetes
insipidus right which is characterized
by excessive thirst um um lots of
urination um and and you know bed
wedding potentially um and so what we
wanted to do was ask has this been
missed right so shouldn't there be a
subset of kids with autism where we
might might be able to look at these
other physiological features and say
yeah this is the subset we want to be
giving vasor pressent to and so she
wrote this perspective where we did a
little bit of a review and the answerers
there's some
intriguing um studies that we reviewed
in this paper where it looks like and
and what's funny is when you read the
discussion section it'll be like wow
there's all these kids with autism that
are drinking lots of water and we don't
know why or wow there's a lot of bed
wedding but it's not tied to
intellectual disability where you might
see a lot of bed wedding or something so
all of these studies kind of raise this
point of like wow this is really
interesting um and there's been no big
epidemiological study done on this and
certainly not any study where people who
come at it from brain science and then
the the practitioners who are like an
endocrinologist for instance which which
is where some of these people could show
up um are are really connecting the dots
so I think that remains to be determined
but we are actually about to launch a
study to to investigate this right I was
meeting with Lauren yesterday about it
so um it's a really good question and I
hope to have information on it in the
not to distant future as I recall
alcohol is an antagonist of vasopressin
so Al there's a lot of different drugs
that could interact with vasor pressent
and so one thing I'm interested in is
are there any drugs that release vasor
pressent as a side effect and could some
of them be mobilized to treat autism we
also know that like um acupuncture can
release phaser and there's been some
studies done in Rats on that um and so
one question would just be are there any
alternative therapies where we can be
relacing vasor pressent naturally or do
we need to you know do a replacement
study where we give you know intranasal
vaser press into children with autism
right and of course I'm I'm not I want
to say I'm not advocating that people go
out and do this on their own right like
I'm I I'm a big proponent of randomized
clinical trials where you assess safety
right and efficacy yes science science
medicine right but I appreciate you
saying that yeah um some years ago so
this would be
mid90s um there was a small but very
active subculture that I was not a part
of okay I swear um that were combining
GHB gah hydroxy butyrate um and
vasopressin as um combination quote
unquote sex drugs really yes yeah um and
I don't know the rationale for including
Bas oppress was in any case whether or
not that's by way of enhancing social
bonding or a direct effect on sexual
arousal itself is still unclear but in
any event since we're talking about Bas
oppressing maybe you should tell us
about the actual science of uh
vasopressin sorry maybe I should allow
you to tell us about the actual
scientific study of vasopressin um in
other words what happens if you give
people Vasa press in a controlled
environment not the sort of environment
I'm talking about but a controll and the
one thing I will say because I have
people contact us all the time saying
where can I get vasor pressent and what
I would say is vasor pressen means you
know you're having effects on blood
pressure you're having effects on really
important right vasod right and vas the
dosing has to be appropriate you know
you don't want people just going and
trying this because there could be
really severe adverse effects right so
that's why we've been studying this in a
in a controll clinical trial right so um
I teamed up with Antonio Harden who's
the child psychiatrist that um I've been
working with for years and we did the
first sort of first inclass vas oppress
treatment trial in children with autism
so again this was everyone was unaware
of who was on basor press whether it was
the family or the clinician who was
doing the evaluation um and then it was
randomized Placebo controlled um and
then we basically gave um vasor presson
again twice a day for four weeks um to
children they were about 6 to 12 years
of age and then we had a primary outcome
measure which was the social
responsiveness scale we could get into
discussions about what a primary outcome
measure should be you know wouldn't it
be great if there was a biological
measure um but this is sort of what had
been used in the past and something that
the FDA approved us using I was partly
interested in using the SRS because we
had used it in monkeys right and we had
shown at least in monkeys we've never
looked at this in people because of you
know the lack of available samples but
that monkeys in this general population
that we've looked at there's a
continuous distribution of these SRS
scores that relate to the CSF vasor
press levels and so what was I wanted to
know if we use the SRS as an outcome
measure and we're administering vasor
presson can we change you know the
scoring on this instrument based on our
animal data so SRS is social social
responsiveness scale corre um without
going into a lot of detail because we
can always refer people to the paper and
I think most people just want to
understand the top Contour um the SRS
presumably has to do with um how often
the kid uh interacts with another kid
how often they initiate that interaction
versus on the receiving end things like
affiliative play um how often they look
at one another versus averting gaze um
these kinds of things yeah and then
there's also um a little bit about
restrictive repetitive behaviors so even
though it's called the social
responsiveness scale there's also an
assessment of other features of autism
in it but you can sort of think about it
as a quantitative way to assess features
of interest in autism and this was
related to our biology and the monkeys
and so then we use this as this outcome
measure um in our trial and and you know
as a as an experimentalist I have this
sort of trust but verify right so you
want to you want to see the same thing
over and over and over again right like
scientists like repetition and so we had
Parents fill out um their impressions of
what the child's uh Behavior was you
know before and after being on the
medication we also had a clinician make
an evaluation but we also had the kids
perform laboratory based tests where
they would see like I mentioned that the
um reading the mind in the eyes test or
we would show them a picture of a a face
and say what emotion is this and so we
were able to have what's called um
converg in validity right so it's a
fancy scientific term to say do all
these measures that we think should be
related are they related and are we
seeing the same thing and um the answer
was yes so that when we gave children
with um autism vasopressin versus kids
with autism of placebo the kids who were
treated with vasopressin showed um
increases in Social abilities on parent
report clinician evaluation and child
performance on laboratory based tests
wow um was that um was that immediate
like they they did the nasal spray and
they immediately started um receiving
and and initiating more social
engagement or was this a buildup over
time and what I'm getting at here is
whether or not this is the reflection of
a short or longer term neuroplasticity
like where there structural changes in
the brain or or is this something that
was more acute um we don't know the
answer to that so we basically looked at
dosing with the idea that we would you
know and and again I think we've
mentioned this about um limitations on
like there's so many things that a
scientist would like to do but you
always limited by a budget right and so
when we started this work again it was
like philanthropic shoestring budgets
right and so you had to really be laser
focused on what are the things that we
can do on the budget at hand so
unfortunately we didn't do like EEG or
brain Imaging or other things that would
be I think potentially very interesting
to do because you might be able to see
an early signature of response right so
maybe after the first dose let's say wow
like there's some interesting changes
that are predictive of somebody who
would be a resp responder to the
medication and we don't know that yet um
but we do know after this 4-week period
that we we saw you know these changes
and in then in a subset of kids we
actually saw diminished anxiety and also
diminished restricted repetitive
behaviors um so suggesting that the
vasor pressent effect may not only be on
um social behavior have you ever just
wanted to try or tried vas oppress you
know I haven't but you're in a
Psychiatry Department after all and I
not suggesting that members of the
Psychiatry Department are constantly
testing the drugs that they use on their
patients with themselves but but I've
had several members of this department
of which I'm a courtesy member um member
by courtesy any event and we'll see if
I'm still am after what I'm about to say
uh Dr Carl dth who's a clinician our
first guest on the huberman Lab podcast
also a phenomenal neurobiology
researcher uh David Spiegel um Rob
malenka um
and others um that I've spoken to you
know I think all of whom said you know
that they felt as clinicians Rob's not a
clinician but anymore right but as a
clinician that they felt almost a
responsibility to understand the effects
and side effect profiles of the drugs
that they were giving their patients
which I saw not as Renegade or
experimental but rather as very
compassionate like seeking empathy um so
I'm curious have you ever just snuck a
little little no no I never have but
there is a long history Medicine of
people trying out they believe so much
in their solution that they go and
vaccinate their family with the new
vaccine that they've created or they try
the medication themselves right so MDMA
was developed by Sasha kogan in a
laboratory in the East Bay first by a
pharmaceutical company in the early
1900s but then kind of disappeared it
did disappear and then it was
resurrected independently in the in the
19 I think 70s and 80s and then now it's
one of the um sort of hot topics items
for the treatment of PTSD still in late
phase clinical trials still illegal but
um self-experimentation is is one of the
central themes of Psychiatry frankly
yeah I mean I guess I you know it's I
Pro I got in trouble in class for being
too social right so so I guess I've
never it might send you over the other
spot yeah yeah exactly who knows but no
I I never no and the thing is is that
these oxytocin Vasa pressin and again
these are done and this is this is
something that I think we've hit on over
and over again in the podcast is you
need to know who's you're studying right
what's the species who's the individual
you know most of these have been done in
you know neuro I mean a lot of the
oxytocin and a little bit of the
vasopress work the single dose work was
mostly done in in what we'll call
neurotypical people right just asking
can we move around social behavior by
just giving this single Drug
Administration most people that are
neurotypical didn't say that they could
tell if they were on the drug or the
placebo right so interesting so I think
the question really becomes you know
drugs have different you know they work
differently based on the individual
who's taking them so if you have a
neurotypical individual and you give
them Vaso presson you know maybe they'll
self-report that they don't see a
difference but if you had somebody who
isn't producing enough phas of presson
maybe you know they would self-report
after a period of time or maybe even
after the first dose wow I really see
something different right did any of the
kids uh report how they felt they just
said like wow I I like playing with
other kids more were they self-aware in
that way and um also feel free to
mention if it feels right to you any um
let's let's consider two outlier cases
one spectacular result if that you know
a kid that went from very socially
isolated to you know maybe very
gregarious and um but let's also balance
that with another outlier the the kid
with low Vasa presson who took Vasa
presson who for whom there was no
significant shift I'm presum that the
data set you probably obser something
like each of those yeah so I mean what
I'll say is that um so yeah I mean there
were definitely kids who didn't respond
to the medication I mean one thing I
think it's important to say and again
this was a small pilot trial right we're
in the process of replicating this in a
much larger sample so you know as a
scientist again you want to say okay
this is really intriguing and
interesting and I've invested a lot in
you know this monkey model and then
doing all the CSF work in patients to
suggests that there may be a there there
here but I want to see it replicate um
we did have an article um that Stanford
medicine I can send you the link um they
they were able to I think interview a
family that had been in the trial um and
so obviously there's patient privacy and
you know you have to they have to say
it's okay to talk about it but this is a
family that was contacted I think they
were Anonymous but this is in this
report um and they basically said the
the dad said that his son was walking
around the he was on Vasa presson and
his son was walking around a grocery
store and he like was looking for him
and he turned around and he said he was
Gob smacked because his child was you
know just talking to making chitchat
with somebody like in an aisle and he
said he had never seen that happen
before um and so you know we do have
anecdotal reports like that and I think
you know the tricky part is are we we
didn't stratify anyone going into this
trial right and so the concern always is
did we get really lucky in the first
trial and we somehow got the the quote
unquote right people that entered the
trial that we're going to be the ones
who would respond to the medication or
is this a medication that has sort of
broad use in this population and we you
know the second trial will be um
positive you used nasal spray to deliver
the vasopress and and um presumably that
gets into the blood circulation of the
brain um and supplies neurons with
vasopressin but it's very non-specific
and I'm not criticizing but if you think
about you just putting a bunch of
vasopressin into the brain and if people
wonder why this is that it's because
basically you have neurons of your
central nervous system um are part of
your factory system and believe it or
not right behind your where your nose
meets your forehead um the brain is
right there there's a little bit of bone
and then the brain is is is right there
so um one of the reasons you can get in
there um and it's easier than an ocular
injection or something that wouldn't be
a good approach and it's easier than a
peripheral in injection into the vein
but at the same time I have to presume
that this I'm imagining this V supress
just kind of like preting through the
brain binding to whatever receptors
happen to be there you said The
receptors are
everywhere and then this significant
Improvement in social cognition right so
that raises all sorts of interesting
questions about like what are what
relevant circuits are impacted um or is
it some Global Inc could it be some
global increase in kind of awareness of
surroundings um although some autistic
kids are overwhelmed by their awareness
of surroundings so um yeah what are some
thoughts about how vasopress might be
working to exert this this really
impressive and frankly important effect
right so I mean could it increase social
motivation does it you know like so
let's talk about like how sort of
complexity of social um sensory
processing is it that were directing
attention to social cues where there
wouldn't have necessarily been as much
iess right um are we increasing social
motivation which would suggest from some
of the animal studies may actually be
happening right um we don't know and I
think that's partly when you have other
models or if you're able you know to do
imaging studies I mean one thing that's
been a little bit of a Holy Grail in
this field is that if we could get um
tracers that are um basically like a you
know a molecule that would allow us to
inject it into somebody and then
visualize the brain like if I'm thinking
about a pet trace or a radi liend where
you could then ask questions about you
know what's happening in the brain can
we can we give vasor pressent in the
context of a you know functional brain
Imaging scan and ask like where is the
vasor press and binding what kind of
circuits are involved like that needs to
be the next step of the work to know
like where where our targets are and you
you can do something like functional
proteomics right where if you know where
basa press and receptors are you can
overlay that with studies of functional
brain Imaging right and that would allow
you to say these areas are dense in
phasor press and receptors and do we see
similar responses in what we call bold
signal on a on a brain scan so let's
let's be more colloquial about this like
do certain areas of the brain light up
if you will where we know vasopress and
receptors are are densely distributed um
in ways that we know are tied to social
motivation or or social salience or
other things that we think could be
moving the needle here um in the trial
how is this happening and and I think
you know one thing the reason why we did
this work is and I think it speaks to
what you said earlier is there is an
urgency on the part of parents to say
you know my child's brain is developing
right and and there's a sense of that
them you know by the sort of Western
model has failed a lot of people you
know they look to doctors and say what
are what are the solutions and doctors
will say well we have a limited number
of tools in the toolkit here we just
don't know right and so you know one of
the reasons why they did that big
oxytocin study was that people were
trying to get the oxytocin anyway so it
was like let's just make sure that this
is safe let's see if it's effective and
so some of our thinking was you know as
soon as some of this work hits you know
like it get and some of the work is been
covered by the media and so you know our
feeling was we can give this intranasal
um and we can do it under safe
monitoring ways um and so people are
going to think about doing these things
anyway so let's just make sure that this
is safe and let's test this in a
rigorous way so we don't know the mode
of action but then our feeling is is
that you know at least from the initial
safety data it looks pretty safe um and
you know and so the idea would be and
there's a long tradition in Psychiatry
if we don't know the the mechanism of
action but if we have a medication that
can be impactful and improve the lives
of people with Autism and we can
diminish suffering and people can more
readily reach their full potential you
know to me it actually seems unethical
not to move forward in a way that's
scientifically sound Amen to
that this seems like a good time to
raise the topic of the microbiome and
not as an unrelated topic and and here's
why um I've seen a fair number number of
studies in Mouse models arguing that in
a mouse model of autism which now
frankly I have to kind of wonder about
the the um Power of that model but
anyway the models are out there in the
field
um
that fecal transplant into a host that
does have social deficits and rescue
some degree of social deficits I don't
know if this has actually been done in
humans as well and for those of you that
are cringing yes they do feal
transplants in humans for treatment of
obesity and a bunch of other things um
this isn't because scientists are
obsessed with feal matter it's because
um feal matter contains a lot of the
microbiome elements um so the
microbacteria of the the of the gut um
and the reason I'm raising this now is
you know one possibility and it it's not
mutually exclusive with a brain
mechanism is that the administration of
vasopressin somehow rescued a vasopress
deficiency in the gut so the questions
are as follows is there any evidence
that vasopress is manufactured in or
impacted by the gut microbiome of humans
we'll just start with humans since I
think most and um because that would
that wouldn't be a Smoking Gun but it'
be an interesting detective story well
okay so the one piece of evidence that I
will say that I find provocative and
fascinating and one thing I want to say
is I I think there's really great work
done in mice I don't want to be a mouse
Basher so I want to just like sort of go
on the record that I'm not bashing other
models um if it's a conser so I think
about everything from like an
evolutionary perspective if a mouse
shares a brain structure with a human
and it's highly conserved you know Mouse
work can be incredibly important and
very impactful right yeah my my lab did
years of mouse work some primate work
where necessary um now I only work on
humans um but um absolutely it has it
has its uses um but clearly the primate
model for social um deficits as it
relates to autism you you at least have
me convinced that that one has a lot of
power let's just say that exactly okay
but I'm going to now say there is a
really cool Mouse study that was done
that I found and there's been you know
lots of different studies so there's
been mice so there's these like I said
these genetically modified mice that
have genetic syndromes that are you know
where the individuals have social
impairments and some of these
individuals and again here's a here's a
problem with a field often they will
measure oxytocin but not vasor pressin
right so like they're not often both
measured together which I always do now
um but there's been some really
interesting evidence that in these Mouse
models that and and again multiple
studies but like certainly low blood
oxytocin levels in these Mouse models
what and and with the sense that maybe
they have some sort of abnormal gut
microbiome and then what they've done is
they've given a probiotic to these mice
normalize their social functioning um
and that in there's an increase in
oxytocin and in a recent study also
vasopressin at the level of the
hypothalamus so by giving a probiotic
you I believe the oxytocin levels were
increased in the blood you saw more
species typical social behavior and this
was all driven by this upregulation of
oxytocin gene expression and also vasor
pressent in this very recent study and
what's interesting is there's this nerve
called the vagus nerve which is uh it's
I think it means the wandering nerve
vagam it's for Vagabond yeah exactly
right
and even it's in the gut but it actually
has a direct projection to the nuclei
and the hypothalamus where oxytocin and
vasor pressent are made how interesting
yes and so when you sever the Vagas you
then in this one study it's a neuron
paper um I think it's like 2020 it's a
super cool paper and then what you do is
you decrease the gene expression and you
don't see the rescue of the oxytocin
levels or the social behavior in this
model so so another words if I interpret
this correctly and I'll go look up the
paper and provide a link to it um
they're they're by increasing the
diversity of gut microbiota because
that's really what a probiotic does sort
of across the board increases the
diversity of gut microbiota no one
specific ilis as I always say because
they all seem to end in ilis you know
multiple Iles Iles ilsy here we go again
um you upregulate gene expression and
thereby action of oxytocin and
vasopressin in the hypothalamus but
that's a neurom mediated thing it's not
as if the microbiota travel to the brain
something changes in the gut which
activates the vagal pathway from gut to
the specific nucleus in the brain and um
we know that the vagal pathway is
involved because it seems at least
partially necessary if you sever that
you give a vagotomy then the uh this
effect is is blunted or eliminated
that's very interesting and and ties the
microbiome to oxy invasor Preston
production in a neural and somewhat
causal way um and makes the data on
fecal transplants make a lot of more
sense because I always wondered okay so
you take a you know taking the
microbiota from one animal putting into
another animal you're creating you're
transferring the millu of the gut but it
doesn't say anything about mechanism
right so this this is a really cool
fascinating and there's also a study
I've always wanted to do is you can get
a vagal nerve stimulator they used to do
them as implants right but you can also
get one that you sort of clip onto the
ear and I've always wanted to ask if we
we use this in autistic individuals and
you know could we increase like can we
alter social behavior right and would
that be something that we could actually
measure in the blood especially if we're
seeing this this change in these blood
levels right are you doing that
experiment no but I've always I've I've
always thought it would be we we have to
get you the to do that experiment and
and I know a few times you've raised the
issue of funding it's not something we
spend a lot of time on this discussing
on this podcast but I think what should
be abundantly clear to the listeners um
throughout the course of this episode is
as you mentioned ear you're very
determined to get work done you'll
figure out a way but the way I describe
um finances and and research is that
it's absolutely necessary but it's not
sufficient you of course have to have
the right people in the right lab head
directing the work but no money no no
project and it and it is disappointing
to see that despite the federal budget
for research being um you know still
reasonable it's not what we would like
it to be um it's still very hard
for amazing worldclass Labs like yours
to say Hey you know listen there's this
vagel thing and clearly there's a
rationale it's not like you're pulling
this out of out of nowhere and um you
want to go do this study but what we're
really talking about is three to five
years of grant writing before you could
even initiate that study meanwhile
autistic kids are going from Age 2 to 5
to six these are critical windows so if
ever there was a um there was a
rationale for um you know moving a lot
of funding to uh you know I don't even
call it highrisk but you know logically
sound hypothesis testing for the
treatment of autism it's it's now so I'm
I'm going to get active on on this front
so I won't get into how but you know uh
when I get something in my uh in my
neural circuits for for talking they
tend to not shut down for a while well
there will be a community that is is
going to be immensely grateful well it
seems like um the parents of these kids
and the kids themselves could greatly
benefit so um you mentioned that the
first study on um vpress Administration
that saw these improvements in Social
functioning you said a small cohort how
many how many kids was It ultimately
that you could use data from okay so we
had I mean you screen a lot so I think
our you know because we had very rigid
criteria so we ended up with 17 kids
that were on active drug and 13 that
were on Placebo and then not a study no
and the placebo CH we we always have
like a humanitarian open label extension
arm which allows for anybody who is in
Placebo can get access to the drug so
both Antonio and I feel very strongly
about making sure that if we're doing a
medication trial everybody can benefit
from it right so afterwards if they say
okay I was in the placebo group but I
really want the chance to try this thing
they can't but then you also get more
data we get right so I think when the
families are now aware that their child
is on basor pressent and the clinicians
are aware you know you really want
there's a huge Placebo response rate
right and so I mean it's not a placebo
response rate here but but we really
would want to make sure that our
evaluation of the social behavior is
done unaware to the medication but you
can get good safety data right so so you
can have those you know 13 children who
were on Placebo we can then also make
sure that their blood chemistry Labs
look good that their cardiograms look
good right and so that also allows us to
assess safety parameters in a greater
number of children in a fairly broad
literature search I was able to find
okay microbiome so feal transplant is
something that people are excited about
as weird and there are trials in people
with Autism ongoing in using feal
transplants okay oxytocin nasal spray
presumably still being investigated by
some groups or it's been abandoned well
I think it's mostly been abandoned
because there's no funding priorities
for it right so so I know that maybe in
Australia because of Adam's positive
findings that I I don't know what his
plans are but maybe he's doing work
there um there might be a little bit of
work with behavioral therapy and
oxytocin but this is the problem when
there's one big trial that fails the
funding just completely dries up so even
if there's promise I don't know a single
funding agency that's going to touch it
got it um and then there's the Vasa
pressen Administration work that you're
doing right I think it's worth
contrasting that work with the Fairly
large trial that was done by a major
pharmaceutical company exploring the
role of vasopress in for the treatment
of autism um you could tell us what they
did because it's
basically the opposite of what you did
um and you can tell us the outcome
because I think that if anything that
study um in advertently Provide support
for the results that you observed which
is that administering let's say
increasing Bas oppress levels in the
brain seems to um ameliorate some of the
social deficits of autism right so um Ro
had a compound called bapin which was a
vasopressin
v1a receptor antagonist which basically
means there's um I think I mentioned
there's these four neuropeptide
receptors and oxytocin vas are present
binding to each other's receptors but
the v1a receptor is the one that is um
most implicated in social behavior um
and so they had and this is the tricky
part about when medications are
developed in in Pharma versus in
academics right in academics there's
definitely this transparency we write
grants the abstracts are are publicly
available we register our trials they do
too but a lot of the shall we say early
development is all put out in
Publications right and then it's also
peer- reviewed and there's you know an
open trail of why we're doing what we're
doing but in a pharmaceutical company
you know they have the ability because
also they have all the funding to be
able to do all kinds of development that
may never see the light of day because
of the proprietary basis of it right and
so you know when you go back to so it's
not it's it still is not clear to me why
they took the approach of using an
antagonist to the main Vaso pressent
receptor in the brain um what's
interesting is if you go back and you
look at the animal literature there are
hamsters that if you give them vasor
presson they become aggressive right and
if you give male Prairie VES vas op
press they can become aggressive but
let's think about the context that
they're doing this in these hamsters
that show aggression are asocial they
live by themselves if you give them vas
oppress and the only social repertoire
they have is to you know have sex with a
female or to fight a male that they see
they have a very limited social rep
right and when the Prairie V male is be
is being given vasopressin it's often in
the context of PR like um protecting his
mate and his offspring and so then it's
actually species appropriate for him to
attack a Marauder male on his territory
who's going to you know kill his babies
right and so so my thinking in reading
the preclinical literature the animal
literature was that all right that makes
a lot of sense in the context of those
species but we've never seen any
evidence in our Tri aggression didn't
change we also have an aggression
measure in this current in the current
trial as well but you know for me the
vast majority of evidence from the
animal literature suggested that Vasa
presson was
pro-social um and that you know
especially given our our CSF findings
like over and over across species across
studies across ages that we we should be
giving vaser presson especially given
the correlations between vaser presson
in CSF and symptom severity and autistic
traits you know the former and people
and the latter in the monkeys um and so
they had some preliminary studies that I
believe were maybe single dose one that
they published um but then they had a
trial where the primary outcome measure
the social responsiveness scale was
negative and then they had um some
secondary measures that maybe showed
some promise and then they were
conducting another trial um and then did
a futility analysis and I know they
stopped the trial and I don't think it
was for safety reasons but again you
know a lot of this isn't made public
right because it's a pharmaceutical
company so you know we we will see
because we are going to be completing
our larger trial you know this year and
you know as they say the proof is in the
pudding so we will see if you know we
can replicate our initial pilot findings
well sounds like they got it backwards
that blocking vasopress Pathways would
just make things worse and that
augmenting Vis oppress and makes things
better um although that last statement
um needs to be supported by this more
extensive population well I think you
know there's been a lot of speculation
and maybe there are people closer to the
trial than me who might be able to speak
to mechanism but you know I would meet
the RO people at conferences and they
would come to my talks and I would
always ask him like what's the mechanism
of action why are you antagonizing the
system when we're giving you know a Vasa
pressent Agonist if you will and you
know some people had said well maybe by
blocking the Vasa presson recept
you know there's a way to have oxytocin
me be more bioavailable that sounds like
some gymnastics yeah yeah I totally
great and so I've never had a I I've
never received a
compelling response from anybody about
why they did their trial and then you
know the differences I mean when when
this was ongoing and you know there was
potentially room for both right um you
know maybe I thought that maybe there's
some some optimal band of Vasa presson
signaling in the the brain right and so
maybe there's some people where they
have too much vasopress and some who
have too little right and so this was a
lot of maybe but it it doesn't to me
seem like that's the case especially if
our current trial has a positive rate
out I'd be remiss if I didn't ask for
your stance and uh read of the landscape
on the data about vacines and autism I'm
not talking about covid vaccines here I
want to be really clear about that but
there was a theory uh running about um
not just in the Press but in um the
scientific literature for a while that
uh vaccines could cause autism yeah that
was proposed um my understanding is that
was
debunked that idea still lives on the
internet um but what is the evidence or
let let's say let's go through this
sequentially what was the idea what was
the evidence for that idea and
then what caused the demise of the the
at least the scientific support for that
idea leaving open of course that new
data may come right but let's talk about
what is known now right and I think what
I will say is being evidence-based is is
sort of like something that all
scientists should strive for right and
so so the the backstory on this is there
was a guy named Andrew Wakefield who
published a paper um and he basically
said the preservatives and vaccines are
causing autism so not the specific
vaccine but the adant the stuff that's
preserving the stuff that's keeping the
the vaccines um bio effective right at
least that was my understanding right
that's mine as well and so and and then
it turn I want to be clear because the
internet is is a is a cruel and um
diabolical place my stance is that that
was the hypothesis I don't agree with
that stance right okay right and so or
if we want to just back up a little bit
broader there was this idea that
something about vaccines were causing a
um autism but the study was debunked he
lost his medical license and the paper
was retracted right well he lost his
medical license on the basis of the fact
that the study was wrong or was there
think he F the data there were that's
why I recall as well that there was
evidence of him literally making up the
data right right so it wasn't a case of
like sloppy technique it was a case of
of intentional fraud right that's my
understanding again what was the did
anyone ever like look into what his
motivation for what what it was like why
someone would I mean threw away his
whole career right yeah I don't I don't
know um but but I think the hard part
about that is understandably people got
very frightened right that we're doing
something to our children that could
have you know un unanticipated
consequences and you know when something
like that happens then we dump a you
know we we spend a lot of money
investigating it and so the the the good
news is at this point there have been
multiple multiple studies that haven't
shown a correlation between you know
vaccines and autism I do believe the
preservatives have been changed as a
result so that's something we should
check um that you know that might be
something where you know there's been a
public health change on preservatives
that are in vaccines that's interesting
in its own right I mean we don't want to
cause alarm if um but that's that's
interesting you know that that in this
data fraud case it might have cued
people to the idea that certain things
might have been um needing change even
though it wasn't the specific issue that
this uh this fraudulent researcher was
focused on the change was made to make
sure people would vaccinate their
children right like so this is something
that I think we should have lots of
caveats here like you know post the post
the studies like make sure that what
we're saying is accurate right but I but
I think that my concern is that we've
spent you know so the good news is that
you know the Maj like every single study
that I'm aware of does not not show a
relationship between vaccination and
autism right and so I think that most
scientists and medical doctors that I
know that are part of like the you know
standard biomed research Community do
not believe the vaccines cause autism
they vaccinate their own children you
know they recommend vaccinations to
other people's children um and and so I
think that's where we are um you know
could I just ask a question um uh and I
feel more than obligated to do this
because I I don't you know I think I
have a pretty good finger on the pulse
of the listenership of this podcast but
I think there's a range of of stances on
this um where some people um have a lot
of trust in the standard medical
establishment others have less right
trust in the standard medical
establishment and I wouldn't be doing my
job if I didn't try and represent um all
those sides um and you know one thing
that I've heard okay is that over the
last 20 or 30 years there's been a
dramatic increase in the number of
vaccinations that kids get and I don't
know if that's true but when we say
vaccinations we could be talking about
you know measles Mom's forella right um
polio um we could also be talking about
measles bumps forbell polio flu shots
every year rabies vaccine technis
vaccine H HPV right with one that wasn't
even available when I was in in college
you know as a everyone in college was
was well aware there wasn't an HPV
vaccine um didn't change people's
behavior a whole lot but um
you
know there's there's a vaccine there's
multiple vaccines and then there's you
know all the vaccines yeah right and I
think that one of the concerns that I
hear about um is the idea that okay
there's some critical vaccines but then
which ones are perhaps less critical if
any um and these are the kinds of
discussions that are starting to surface
um and that you know have parents and
potential parents you know rightfully
thinking about this stuff and and no one
really knows where to get the
information but like I'm I I've tried
and I can't find a pediatrician that
says Hey listen these but not those or
you can certainly find board certified
Physicians that say many and certain
board certified Physicians that say none
you actually can find those um the none
category tend to hide themselves a
little bit more than others for obvious
reasons but it's hard to get a sense of
like which which vaccines are critical
and which ones aren't if you're a parent
and you're not versed in this stuff and
so you could imagine that like people
are you know kids are taking many more
vaccines and only some of those are
critical or maybe all of them are
critical well I think I guess the way I
would maybe turn it on its head is that
you know because of
this this study that did in some ways so
much harm right like we SPI study we
spent I I I don't even want to Hazard a
guess about how much money worldwide
went into studying you know the the you
know vaccine and autism based on a
fraudulent data right like that's to me
a real tragedy but at the time they
didn't know it was fraudulent exactly so
they went after this thinking it was
true okay but I think I think the thing
the consequence of all this that I think
is also extremely sad is that
everybody because everyone got so riled
up and so fearful there has been
historically until recently many
researchers who were like oh man I don't
want to touch IM mology and autism with
a 10-ft pole right and yeah you know and
I I wouldn't consider myself Fearless
but like my lab never had any reason to
work on those yeah on those important
problems but I'll tell you like it seems
like a it's not a kettle of fish it's
it's a ball of barbed wire with a bunch
of you know Napalm burning around it and
you know I mean you say one thing your
your career is ending you say the
opposite thing your career is also
ending you know it's it it's it's a it's
a mess but but I think this highlights
that there are so many parents you know
again and I think we need to listen to
parent stakeholders right like you know
there's there needs to be a dialogue
whenever anybody's studying any illness
to to talk to the people who are
involved right and and I think that
there are parents who will report wow
like there are there is immune system
disregulation in my child and but
because of this historical issue with
vaccines it's only been very recently
that I think people scientists medical
doctors have said okay we're hearing a
lot about this from parents and are
there a group of individuals who have
you know um immune issues that could be
driving their autism right we don't know
and everything should be evidence-based
but I think that like you said with this
cancel culture and all this fear
scientists sometimes will pick topics
very judiciously based on you know like
hey I just want to be left in peace and
I'm trying to help this community and if
there is areas of the Enterprise that
you think are going to cause all kinds
of grief then people are going to be
less reluctant to study them even if
it's critically needed well that's a a
perfect place to say thank you I realize
you're not addressing the vaccine autism
issue directly but you're so clearly
going after the target trying to figure
out what are the biological mechanisms
that are disrupted in autism and by
extension other deficits of social
function in kids and adults you've
identified this incredible relationship
between
vasopress which should have more
prominence in my opinion than oxytocin
its lesser cousin just kidding oxytocin
lovers um but also have shown you know
yes in a small study but you're now
extending this to a larger cohort as you
mentioned uh a causal relationship when
B oppress is administered to these low
vasopress SL low social functioning kids
their symptoms improve so I I know I
speak for many people when I say that um
I truly appreciate your doggedness in in
going after this problem especially on
the complicated landscape of lack of
funding for doing novel and truly
high-risk work um especially on the
backdrop of the sociopolitical landscape
around autism it's a complicated thing
even to discuss you know as I mentioned
in the introduction you know we had to
have some fluency around autism so we
sometimes said autistic sometimes we
said people with Autism you know I mean
it's a it's a tough one but in order to
make progress real progress in this area
we need people like you we need you and
you're doing it to get in there and just
go okay you know let's get at the
biological functions let's get at the
novel treatments and you're making
amazing progress so I'm so grateful that
you're doing it and that you'll continue
to do it and that you came here today um
to teach us what you've been up to um
I'm oh so grateful and I just want to
say thank you for that and that we
absolutely have to get you back here uh
to give us an update on your progress
really soon and and again and again and
again thank you so much I love being
here all right well I've Loved this
conversation and um I'll sign off by
saying folks this is how diseases are
cured thank you for joining me for
today's discussion with Dr Karen Parker
about the biological basis of social
functioning and autism to learn more
about Dr Parker's research
please see the links in our show note
captions if you're learning from and or
enjoying this podcast please subscribe
to our YouTube channel that's a terrific
zero cost way to support us in addition
please subscribe to the podcast on both
Spotify and apple and on both Spotify
and apple you can leave us up to a
five-star review if you have questions
for me or comments about the podcast or
guess you'd like me to consider on the
hubman Lab podcast please put those in
the comment section on YouTube I do read
all the comments please also check out
the sponsors mentioned at the beginning
and throughout today today's episode
that's the best way to support this
podcast not so much on today's episode
but on many previous episodes of The
huberman Lab podcast we discuss
supplements while supplements aren't
necessary for everybody many people
derive tremendous benefit from them for
things like improving sleep for hormone
support and for improving Focus to learn
more about the supplements discussed on
the hubman Lab podcast go to live
momentus spelled o us so live mous.com
huberman if you're not already following
me on social media I am huberman lab on
Instagram X formerly called Twitter
LinkedIn Facebook and threads and at all
of those places I discuss science and
science related tools some of which
overlaps with the content of the
huberman Lab podcast but much of which
is distinct from the content covered on
the hubman Lab podcast so again it's
hubman lab on all social media channels
if you haven't already subscribed to our
neural network newsletter our neural
network newsletter is a zeroc cost
newsletter that comes out every month it
includes podcast summaries as well as
protocols in the form of short PDFs of
maybe just one to three pages where I
list out the specific protocols for
instance for improving dopamine
functioning or for improving your sleep
or for deliberate cold exposure
deliberate heat exposure or Fitness
protocols and on and on all of which are
presented in brief fashion very direct
just the protocols listed out again
completely zero cost to sign up you
simply go to huberman lab.com go to the
menu function scroll down to newsletter
and enter your email and I should point
out that we do not share your email with
anybody thank you once again for joining
me for today's discussion with Dr Karen
Parker and last but certainly not least
thank you for your interest in
[Music]
science